big news alec baldwin shot and killed a
woman on the set of the film rust and
we've got a whole bunch of new details
coming out
and we got a lot to talk about it turns
out a couple new details it was a live
round
and apparently the crew had walked off
set the day i believe days prior because
the gun had misfired before
so here we go
i'm going to say it alec baldwin is more
than 100 responsible for this we'll get
into all of these details i don't want
to just rush into it you know head first
we've also got some other really uh um i
guess more ridiculous news
interestingly joe biden came out with
this psa where he's speaking with a
disabled man who is saying that thanks
to build back better he's able to have
his you know his live in assistance
helping him live the life he does and
the man's name is brandon and so a lot
of people think you know this is an out
of place psa this is the biden
administration's attempt to reclaim the
name brandon and i'm willing to predict
that the media is going to say anybody
who says let's go brandon is clearly
mocking a disabled man okay this should
be funny we got a lot to talk about we
got some awesome friends who have joined
us we got viva and barnes
this is i was telling you earlier this
is a surreal experience i've met robert
for the first time tonight
for the first time and the team for the
first time tonight so two years we've
known each other and now we finally get
to meet well you've been uh um basically
locked up in the gulags of uh canada for
the past for your entire life i believe
right well i i didn't realize i was
locked up until the last two years and
then i realized we were locked up when i
was asked for you know documentation to
travel from quebec to new brunswick but
getting here was a journey i had to get
you know proof from you guys that i was
coming down for legit non-vacation
reasons wow uh negative uh rapid tests i
brought papers just in case they asked
and uh i got through the customs and it
was it was a good feeling
let's get in depth on that later on
we'll we'll jump into that robert barnes
yeah glad to be here yeah what what's
your story i mean you guys should
introduce yourselves i guess oh yeah so
uh robert barnes barnes law this is viva
fry so the uh vivabarnslaw.locals.com
uh it's uh i mean it's great to be here
it's great it's finally good to meet up
i mean basically it was two and a half
years ago uh aviva covered uh alex
jones's deposition and i was alex
jones's lawyer at the time and then all
of a sudden the pandemic happened and
the world went crazy
well there you go
it was the coolest thing i was so naive
at the time in the background i heard i
like your work mr barnes there was the
other lawyer who said it after the
deposition and i only put it together
after like the first time we spoke but
uh yeah barnes was the lawyer in the
background of that alex jones episode
who was the deposing lawyer uh complete
nut job let me complete lunatic i can
say that now cause i'm not part of the
case so yeah i mean just a complete just
just a whack job all the way uh mark
bankston uh just sort of lefty hardcore
had a fake anonymous twitter account
where he was saying all the things he
was accusing other people of doing uh i
mean just just insanity so you guys are
lawyers you comment on cultural issues
in law and it's really fascinating how
people you know uh i know i love
watching your videos because i'm like i
need to understand this you know someone
who's actually
a lawyer but you're canadian so it
doesn't count well no i'm canadian and i
was looking into the u.s stuff to try
and make it make sense of it for myself
and then that's you know how i fell into
the niche it's just trying to understand
justice mollet's deferred prosecution
agreement right that i realize other
people don't know what it means and so
i'm a lawyer not a u.s lawyer i can make
sense of these terms and then explain it
to people who don't understand it we
gotta we gotta this will be helpful when
we talk about the south baldwin stuff so
we'll definitely get into it i
definitely wanna approach that from uh a
gun connoisseur perspective but i think
you guys will have a legal perspective
which would be interesting and you as a
canadian probably have a lot of
questions in fact about how yeah i i'm
gonna be the uh the know-nothing when it
comes to guns because i know nothing
when it comes to guns but knowing law
should be interesting because you can
ask those questions so we'll get into
all that stuff we've got luke you're
canadian you get a pass um today i'm
wearing one of the most classiest shirts
from my collection
and it states tax this
danny
and i have my family-friendly tape here
so if you really want to know what it
says you can find out by going to
thebestpoliticos.com thanks for having
me and i'm looking forward to this
conversation oh man me too ian crossland
of course here what's up dudes i'm glad
you guys are here in the flesh this is
great for the first time and i don't
want to waste any more time let's go i
am so excited to be the one facilitating
these two guys meeting it was like an
act of god to get all of this lined up
in time just like our event tomorrow so
i'm stoked to have you guys here have a
great conversation and don't forget to
go to timcast.com become a member sign
up help support our journalists help us
make more content we've already got the
cass castle vlog tales from the inverted
world the crew has been working on this
new pop culture show we're going to be
producing so we want our values freedom
personal responsibility we want these
things to come out in the content we
produce so we're doing more and that's
thanks to your membership again at
1ps.com and we're also doing an event
tomorrow night
in the harpers ferry area and there's
going to be
it's not just going to be the tim cast
irl crew we got ryan long and danny
polish chuck who are going to be doing
comedy you know ryan and danny from the
videos he puts out that are amazing and
then there's probably a bunch of other
people showing up who happen to be in
the area for some reason
they might be here for some reason and
they might end up at the event as well
yeah and a couple people who live in dc
so i think a lot of people are gonna be
really pleasantly surprised to see that
we somehow managed to pull together a
large group of people for this what was
kind of just a random event um but as a
member those who are at the 25 level or
more the tickets were free they're sold
out now we are currently doing an
auction for another set of tickets and
then because i guess we're out of time
we're gonna do one more auction for a
very limited amount of time for four
tickets
so that should be up at some point maybe
now actually i'm not entirely sure but
uh yeah so we're auctioning those off
and then if you are a member at the 25
level we're actually going to seek out
bigger venues because our intention was
never to gate it so that 10 members
couldn't get it it was that we wanted to
create something that was like okay if
you're you know a dedicated fan and you
really want to support us then we'll
give advance notice of our events
considering we sold out faster than i
realized we would i guess i
underestimated you know uh how much
people really want to come to events
like this we're we're going to do a much
bigger venue the next time around and
then we'll be able to and the tickets
are free we're going to do to the best
of our abilities we're trying to do free
events for our members so that's another
thing you'll get uh the challenge i
suppose is if the venues don't allow us
to do that this time around we're
covering all the costs pretty expensive
but i think it's totally worth it
because real world events are where
people form those bonds make those
connections meet friends
get married even maybe who knows so
that's why we're doing it so definitely
thanks uh thanks for being a member
like this video subscribe to this
channel all that stuff let's just get
into it let's talk about some news we
got some some new information on the
alec baldwin shooting from the la times
rust crew describes onset gun safety
issues and misfires days before fatal
shooting in fact they say
hours before the out the actor alec
baldwin fatally shot a cinematographer
on the new mexico set of rust with a
prop gun a half dozen camera crew
workers walked off the set to protest
working conditions the camera operators
and their assistants were frustrated by
the conditions surrounding the low
budget film including complaints about
long hours long computes and collecting
their paychecks according to three
people familiar with the matter who are
not authorized to comment
we're also learning i believe we have
this story it's from people the gun alec
baldwin fired on rust set contained a
live round prop masters union says now
this is normally i don't care too much
about the pop culture stuff it's not
policy i'm but this is alec baldwin an
overtly political actor a violent and
angry individual on online who has been
a very prominent activist whether you
like it or not or you think it's silly
he has been
he is
you know look many of these people i
don't want to say him directly but i'd
assume him along with many others are
anti-gun and this is how it manifests
they want to play with weapons on set
and they don't take responsibility for
it so this is a gun issue it's a
political issue and now i'm seeing all
of these people tweet at me it's not
alex baldwin's fault no no i said it
it's more than 100 his fault because not
only at the time when i said that if the
gun is given to you it is in your hand
you are responsible for what comes out
of it period that doesn't mean he's a
murderer it just means he's responsible
it could be negligence it could be
manslaughter or it could be accidental
but it's on him the other issue is now
that we're learning that the crew had
been describing gun safety issues
already
if he was not aware of that when he was
handling a weapon his fault yeah so
here's my one question as an ignorant
canadian i took a firearm to safety
course but i when i saw the term misfire
i just asked the question is it not
firing when it's supposed to or is it uh
firing by accident i look this up a
misfire means that it doesn't fire at
all then there's a thing called a hang
fire where it doesn't fire for about 30
seconds and then it fires okay that's
interesting i don't know about if it
just goes off without even touching it
if that's also considered a misfire i
couldn't figure that out well another
thing we have to add to this discussion
is that if someone knows gun safety if
someone knows how to use guns some if
someone is properly trained on how to
use gums they could prevent a lot of
these incidences from happening because
you know hey i got a real gun i got real
bullets and you know the difference
between fake bullets dummy bullets fake
guns prop guns and rail guns so this is
uh this is a huge tragedy uh we're
hearing other reports that uh alex said
why was i given a live gun after this
incident so again i have to kind of say
he's here it's hot didn't he say yeah
yeah i believe something along those
lines the the reports are still coming
in the police say that they're still
investigating all of this but it is very
prominent that a lot of the people who
are the most anti-gun don't know
anything about guns and that's that's
something that should be stopped
immediately and people should take some
time and and learn about them because uh
i mean these incidences could be
prevented with just information and
knowledge but sadly a lot of the times
we can't even talk about these issues so
i tweeted that this is alec baldwin's
fault i didn't say he should go to
prison i didn't say you know in in one
tweet i i have expressed that you know
he should be charged um to a certain
degree there should be an investigation
i'll put it that way but i get all these
these lefties these these you know
because they love alec baldwin because
he is in their tribe they're like it's
the prop master's fault and i'm like
prop master wasn't holding a gun it's
it's crazy to me people then said so tim
actually believes in more gun control
now and i'm like yo i'm pretty sure it
is the two-way advocates who are the
ones demanding responsibility for gun
owners not the government imposing
restrictions on the people
so well we'll just contrast it to the
car rentals case i mean kyle rittenhouse
actually knew how to use a gun only used
it in self-defense purposes and they
were eager for him to be prosecuted with
every imaginable crime even crimes that
didn't apply to him under the
constitutional circumstances and yet
here you have a celebrity a high-profile
personality overtly political over the
last decade uh who chose to be very
anti-gun who killed somebody because he
didn't have basic training and and
that's it that's right how do i mean i
don't even understand how they have a
live gun on a set i appreciate it's a
prop and that to me means there should
never be anything near bullets in it so
is it is it shooting a shell of a of a
blank bullets bullets are banned from
these kinds of movies so how did this
happen i mean there's a lot of
accusations about how the workers were
treated here there's a lot of
accusations about scabs getting crazy
there's a lot of you know a lot of
implications with people just being
brought in out of nowhere so i mean this
happened before it's not like this never
happened before this happened to brandon
lee bruce lee's son was shot and killed
because of another accident where
someone had a live bullet on uh you know
the production facility so they made
sure to ban all live bullets from
production facilities and and this
happened again i don't think it's an
accident i'm not saying it was an
intentional murder or anything like that
but you know when i'm thinking about
this story
i got my biases all right and i'll tell
you one of them we've got some replica
guns here we've got uh we've got airsoft
we have actual mock replicas for like
basic training purposes it's like a
piece of metal that just slides back
doesn't really do much
and you know i was just explaining to to
the viva barnes before we started the
show like i'll also ask someone like hey
you know the gun safety rules right
never pointed anybody finger off the
trigger the gun is always loaded and
i'll hand them the weapon and the first
thing they always do is just like oh wow
and i'm like your finger's on the
trigger and you're pointing it at people
you see you failed the test when you do
that when i so they say oh but alec
baldwin's got training and he's safe my
assumption
is that he was goofing around he did not
respect that weapon he clearly did not
check it if they're saying it was a live
bullet that means he didn't open it up
and say
you got to be handed the okay if it's if
you're getting a revolver the revolver
should be open pointed down handed to
you by the by the armor of the set the
prop master who says this is a colt 45
loaded with 45 you know 45 long call
revolver we are closing the revolver now
when you pull the trigger it will fire a
live round he's handed a gun he doesn't
look at he doesn't open he doesn't check
and then it misfires whatever whatever
whatever that means i'll play devil's
advocate because i really don't like
alec baldwin but um is setting aside the
politics is overt you know hateful
rhetoric irrelevant for the time being
if i'm alec baldwin and i'm a hollywood
actor and someone says this is a prop
for a scene here you go take it look
i don't even know how but i know that
it's real it's easy with
let's make a legal argument of it a
legal argument out of it
i hand ian a loaded gun
and i say don't worry ian it's not
loaded you can shoot viva and then he
does
will ian get in trouble if well
at that point a loaded gun or sorry a
real gun i would say yes but i said i'd
probably
say it's a prop i don't even have a
reason to know that it's a real gun i
would say you're the one who's going to
be guilty of setting up something
cataclysmic because if i have no reason
to believe it's a real gun do you think
a court would would tell like if i say
this is a prop gun don't worry go ahead
and point it at him and pull the trigger
the court's going to be like no no it's
not ian's fault he was just pointing a
gun and pulling the trigger the problem
is someone gave him bad info if alec
baldwin was a 20 year old actor never
done anything before that might work but
the problem is he's been around for too
long so he does know exactly what a prop
gun is i mean if i was looking at
prosecuting him i would be looking at
that experience and that would be the
problem it's not just
sorry sorry
there was a a comment from someone i
think one of the one of the uh someone
who's worked with baldwin who said they
worked with him before they knew he was
well trained and very safe that's
actually a really good point you could
argue there's no way he wouldn't have
known yeah there's also a difference
between blanks and real bullets you
could tell the difference just by
looking at them you know blanks
obviously don't have that top part and
that that projectile that goes and
yeah the bullet uh so so obviously the
two are very different and if someone
you know just checked someone just
looked at it and especially if he's just
picking up a firearm he i mean i wish he
would have checked but here's the other
thing my understanding is they never
actually point the guns at people anyway
that's the other bottom line even with
my kid we tell not to point the nerf
dart gun at people because you just
don't do it out of habit this i'm i'm
only giving him the benefit of the doubt
that if he has no reason to believe it's
a real gun
holding live rounds and i don't even
know why that would be on a set how it
gets there in the first place and you
may have cumulative responsibility here
one aspect of negligence coupled with
another how did it get there everybody
sued for myself
i'm kind of wondering about a criminal
element here sabotage is a interesting
creative thought
i don't even think about that you've got
a crew that's walking off protesting
saying the conditions are bad you've
also probably got low budget people who
aren't being you know properly vetted
someone put a live ball in that gun yeah
i mean why workers were sending out
messages on social media saying things
like quote i am literally on the show in
new mexico with him and the producers on
that movie are are treating the local
crew like effing dog uh crap i'm not
gonna family friendly show so i can't
say that but that's exactly what one of
the workers uh a part of this crew said
and he goes on and he details a lot
about a lot of bad conditions i'm doing
a little bit of speculation here too but
we were we were uh asking you know
everybody's been asking like what kind
of gun was it what kind of round was it
here's here's my my best guess because
we don't have all the full details we
got this from imdb a 13 year old boy
left to fend for himself and his younger
brother following the death of their
parents in 1880s kansas
all right
well what kind of gun would they be
using in a movie about the 1880s i'd
imagine it's going to be a revolver
i'm not an expert on this stuff but i'd
imagine that he was armed with a 45 long
coal and so i guess what happened was
the single bullet went uh hit the woman
and then it went through her and then
hit
the director as well and he didn't have
life-threatening injuries he went to the
hospital some people were speculating
that it was a blank and it shattered the
camera sending shrapnel into her or
something like that but now we have we
have the article from the people
apparently union was saying it was a
live round and a live run that went
through one person and then hit a second
person that went to the hospital and so
luke mentioned this look was like it
must have been a 45 and i was like 45.
it went through one person i know so i
mean
there needs to be a lot of power and i'm
asking myself why would the gun be
pointed at the cinematographer in any
case when i first heard the story i
thought maybe it was the stunt person
involved but why would the gun have been
pointing been pointed at a
cinematographer i'm thinking he was
shooting towards camera she was right on
the camera and he was shooting like
right past it and the director was
behind her on the monitor watching so
they were both there in the line and he
was just like you don't even pay
attention to the crew when you're acting
it's like they're not there pretty much
and so that was probably going through
his mind actually i i think that's a
good possibility uh you know ian's point
uh often when people are learning how to
shoot when they grip the gun incorrectly
they could squeeze their hand causing
the handgun to move in other directions
so
what i've been told when i've gone to
these classes is that people will
typically pull down when they pull the
trigger their hand makes the barrel
point down yeah but some people will
pull left so if alec baldwin has the gun
and he squeezes his hand not knowing how
to use the weapon and it causes the
barrel to shift to the left and she's to
his left he hits her one thing that's
concerning is they called a misfire a
misfire by definition means that it
never went off so it wasn't a misfire it
was maybe a hanging fire or maybe it
just got fired accidentally which i
don't think is considered a misfire i
still have diff great difficulty
understanding why there's a live bullet
that's why it sounds criminal it it
there's an interesting aspect given the
tweets set on you know the ambiance on
the set the environment on the set it
sounds like there might have been
something else like potential sabotage
wow but i would before blaming alec
baldwin in as much as i loathe him as a
politician political character i i would
i would say there should never be
bullets on a set and right it'll be
everybody that rule already exists yeah
so i don't know if it wasn't followed
then then there's going to be some
production companies
why didn't he know i mean that's the
problem right he's done this a lot how
did he not know there was so do you
think criminal
i mean
he should be under criminal
investigation without that people are
saying manslaughter well
uh civil easily uh against everybody
against everybody yeah but criminally
you'd have to investigate and you'd want
to investigate everything connected to
her whether there could be a backstory
here they're beyond the union backside i
mean you know look i don't want to jump
the shark on our speculation but having
an affair
you would definitely look at that right
and you'd have to look at that right
there's a very interesting video of a
crew with will smith looking at replica
and fake alleged firearms um and you see
one of the crew members pick it up and
point it directly at will smith will
smith smacks it out of his hands
takes out the magazine i saw this going
around on instagram um takes takes out
the firearm puts it in the safe
direction takes out the magazine and of
course checks it to make sure that
there's nothing in there and then hands
it back to the crew member being like
these people aren't uh following basic
gun safety rules here but but he was
taking it seriously on a movie set
because you know a lot of these prop
guns are usually just real guns with
blank bullets check it out we got it
this is uh this was bad boys
yeah so
yeah so
you can see it that right is gonna
happen now that guy points it right into
his face
boom smacks it down grabs it out
checks the clip well this is this one
he does it right thank you will
and then and then he goes like the ends
yeah that looks like it might have been
a setup promo for the movie that's
pretty i mean it could have been that's
great
um what was the other thing i was going
to say i forgot now it'll come back but
i mean he's he's done it too long not to
have known something was wrong so he had
to be out of it yeah oh this is what i
was going to say that it's for everybody
out there they should know also that
having blanks in there doesn't
necessarily make it 100 safe either from
the uh brandon lee story no no that's
the i think hexam which is one that had
the leftover shell from the black no no
no no the black so blanks kill you
uh a blank will kill you people so i've
got a revolver i've got the governor
smith and western governor and you know
i went to a range i brought some weapons
asked the guys like give me give me give
me a lowdown tell me what for and one of
the things i said is don't put your
hands don't hold the revolver with your
hands where the the uh the cylinder is
because the gases and the explosion come
out sideways so you gotta you'll hurt
yourself
that's just the concussive force of the
round a blank itself has enough power to
kill you at close range
so that that story i guess was like in
1984 a guy on the set of a tv show had a
gun with a blank in it and he just
took himself out the brandon lee thing
they had dummy rounds which are
improvised from live cartridges they
have the powder removed but in that his
case they didn't remove the powder okay
all right we're going to do a hard segue
off this topic because someone just uh
because i want to but someone also
chatted biden is a blank okay good
enough for me
so i saw this tweet and a lot of other
people were commenting something similar
this is president biden tweeting i'm
fighting every day to pass my build back
better agenda for folks like brandon his
story is like so many i've heard across
the country folks are just looking for a
fighting chance and to be treated with
the dignity they deserve and that's what
my agenda is all about i saw this video
and my first reaction was they're trying
to hijack let's go brandon
and
there's a disabled man named brandon
saying thank you joe biden for a build
back better it's because of this plan i
can keep you know my living assistance
and i'm like that's just wrong this poor
guy this poor guy first of all he didn't
pass bill back better it's not going to
happen mansion and cinema are saying no
and it really feels like this was a pr
campaign because let's go brandon for
those that don't know means f joe biden
and it's viral
it's viral
sports games colleges
uh apparently i was reading like people
at a gun range were yelling it yeah that
one's obvious so viral it's generating
apparently fake news stories out of
canada which was some government agency
out of canada saying in a formal memo
that you're not allowed seeing let's go
brandon or any variation thereof yeah
apparently it turned out to be fake but
uh it's my number one t-shirt seller my
let's go brandon sure it's the number
one that people are buying more than
anyone else so this is caught on like
wildfire now it means this nice little
disabled guy
right gop congressman ends floor speech
with let's go brandon florida rep bill
posey
at the top of the charts talking about
it i mean this says caught on and
there's something to say about this
brilliant but what's actually terrible
is you're not allowed saying it in
certain places or it's become taboo
where uh
canada oh no
you don't say because it's a political
statement now
they still can't say for this guy his
name may very well be brandon and now
nobody can cheer him on right
you say hijacking it might just be
co-opting or they might want to flip it
around where now whenever they say let's
go brandon it's going to have a positive
tone that biden's going to be able to
say look they're cheering on my campaign
could you imagine if biden ends up doing
a video where you or like jen sackey
they'll like a clip of people going
let's go brandon you know and then she's
going to be like people are really
picking up our campaign they're really
excited well it's memes come to life
because you know there's all the memes
of biden talking to obama saying they're
cheering his name they're doing all
these things they want to have sex with
him that's what it all means and now
it's going to be for real life though
trump would have never made this mistake
just because the association is biden
with
disability in such a way that you know i
don't know if i would associate myself
in that way i feel bad for the guy man
yeah he's just being completely
manipulated so good news he's being used
he's being exploited for uh an aspect of
identity politics that's just it's just
cheap politics just
bring up people to garner sympathy but
also it's going to reflect poorly on
biden that's for sure it remind
everybody of it i mean why don't remind
somebody if something is a weakness
right yeah that's what trump was really
good at completely don't talk about you
know rope in a house with his been a
hanging yeah yeah yeah and that's why he
would label people with names yes sleepy
joe
crooked hillary crooked hillary uh what
was the other one there for bush bush
was low energy
low energy
and then he got uh cruz was
landline
and then my favorite was when uh the
trump supporters turned lion like lying
into lion like rar
they were like he's lying ted but it's
the good one now pretty clever
well you know little marco
will marco
man trump was good at it he was you know
and that we all remember them without
much help is amazing how the branding
worked so this is interesting though
trump was really good at meaning
like the naming people
even now with trump you know kind of
behind the scenes doing the trump social
stuff
people have just created another meme
that's gone viral and everyone's
laughing and loving it and i think when
you see the uh we pulled up the civics
uh polling
joe biden's approval rating among
independent voters is 26 percent
well he's just thinking like remarkably
bad terrible terrible i mean when you
see football games in their chanting
let's go brandon like these are regular
people these are not political
individuals well the last time we saw
this kind of same similar culture
jamming was with jeffrey epstein with
the memes with the messaging everyone's
screaming jeffrey epstein did not uh
kill himself do something to himself and
obviously but that caught on everywhere
on national television people
interrupted broadcasts people were
bringing it up in just the most weirdest
random points and and that caught on
because there was this a major
disassociation from the mainstream from
the narrative from of course everything
the establishment wanted you to know and
think about and then people saying hey
we're actually paying attention here
you're full of crap we're going to let
you know about it by putting this into
the culture so this is another example
of this on another level which is pretty
pretty awesome and interesting to see
for the one viewer out there who might
not know the whole story it's brandon
brown from nascar wins the nascar and
everyone in the background chanting f
joe biden and the reporter says hey you
hear them saying let's go brandon wow
it's the simpsons again predicting the
future the simpsons have done it time
and time again here it's
right
it would be a joke if it weren't so darn
funny actually
i keep seeing posts where it's like we
live in a simulation because it's just
become so
uh life is a parody of itself at this
point how stupid everything's become
they call it a simulacrum where there's
like it's like a false
essence of a simulation where they're
showing you they're like actively trying
to show you a fake reality
let's go brand-name and are they it was
so obvious that they were trying to be
like uh what do we do when i was i was
on newsmax sean spicer's show and they
were like they played the clip and you
hear beep joe biden
joe but i'm laughing because i'm like
the beeps because like we know what
they're saying
i just i'm just imagining now like
i'm sorry this campaign they're doing
with this disabled guy
it seems so obvious it's cheap and
exploitive but i will say i will say i
would not be surprised if biden comes
out and tries claiming the let's go
brandon chance are for him now yeah
because look
the people who support the democrats
are not going to back away from that
and they will be like see and you'll be
like guys it's not true
every time a story comes out about trump
and it's proven to be false or fouchy
lies to congress and then you get all
these democrats on reddit and twitter
being like aha facie's so smart and you
prove it's wrong they don't accept
reality they just point to you and say
you're a q a on conspiracy theorists and
i'm like bro i don't know anything about
those guys but i'll tell you this
they're not the ones in in cnn they're
not the ones in the white house or
congress maybe like one or two people if
you want to be very critical but
y'all like
all of you except for like a very small
faction are totally in on this insanity
this fake news well it's just redefining
language i mean it's to the point where
fully vaccinated is now not going to
mean fully vaccinated within a couple of
weeks well well hold on
what does fully vaccinated even really
mean
the cdc
definition or the the real life
definition that other countries are
using because there's a difference well
so now university of denver is going to
mandate the flu vaccine nope so if
they're like are you fully vaccinated
it's like well look me personally i've
got a bunch of vaccines so many so i
don't know what full counts to you but
you know to drop a little quebec uh
politics fast while ago the premier of
quebec when he tweeted it out he didn't
use fully vaccinated he used it was in
french adequate vaccine adequately
vaccinated which i uh pointed out that's
great that's nice fluff talk there
because that means two doses is not
going to be enough very soon no there's
no question it's going to be a it's
going to be a constantly evolving term
and it's going to be absorbing other
vaccines and other issues now the
government knows it can mandate what it
can put into your body and it's going to
expand into other issues as well the
other day luke claimed that bill gates
was funding a microchip that can make
you fertile or that could turn on and
off fertility through a touch of a
button and i told him he was crazy until
i googled it and it's true
bill gates funded uh um implantable uh
um contraceptive contraceptive right
microchip
but it's a contraceptive that you can
control with an app and so actually that
innocently you know sounds great right
an individual who wants to you know a
woman or presumably a guy wants to go on
birth control they can just turn their
phone on and then they won't have kids i
can turn it off but you know just sounds
so nefarious when you think about it
yeah you know bill gates and other
people who believe in population control
also having that ability to turn
people's fertility on and off you know
there's nothing wrong with that
it's just you take the chinese social
credit model and you apply it much
broadly because i mean what he did in
india in terms of controlling people's
biometric identification purposes of
financial access for transportation for
travel you just add vaccinations one
child policy what you guys need to
understand what people need to
understand is when you go on twitter and
you see the woke left the establishment
democrats
that is the social credit system they
are currently living in it
and so that's why a lot of people won't
speak out there there may be people
watching right now who are like i can't
stand what's happening around me but i'm
not going to say anything
congratulations you live in the social
credit system the only thing you're
missing is the app so they can read your
your your score but if you're going to
abide by all of their rules and adhere
to all of it that's it well there
already is a social credit score but
it's not like the the people in china
have to deal with it's a corporate one
here when many corporations have almost
every aspect of your existence
written down recorded and then they have
a certain score that they allocate you
on how many advertisements they could
sell you but also your political stances
what you believe in where you should be
ranked in the algorithm how much you
should be promoted where you're going to
land on the news feed even if you're
going to be shown on the newsfeed so
there's already a social credit score
here in the united states with many
multinational corporations that have
implemented it with real life
consequences because people speak wrong
think and get punished for it already
real life consequences luke i think i'm
gonna i'm gonna have to ask you to be a
little bit uh more sensitive to we have
a refugee from canada here
i'm going back on sunday he didn't say
sorry yeah they let me back in why are
you coming back are you crazy i got my
family in canada get him out
go to mexico we'll see what happens in
the future there canada's going off the
rails now if anybody hasn't seen trudeau
going has been no it's getting it's
getting worse true trudeau put out a
tweet that says uh you know when uh
health canada approves the new vaccine
we're ready to go with it for eight kids
five to eleven yeah so he's appealing to
his own organization that's under
federal control effectively to approve a
vaccine that he's already purchased for
the use that he intends on getting
approval for and tell me that's not a
fact but i mean can you travel
domestically without a vaccine passport
in canada well as i think it's as of
november yeah 12 years old and up if
you're not fully vaccinated you cannot
take a plane or train uh yeah so that's
crazy so uh
is where you live known
uh oh yeah no i'm in montreal everybody
knows that i just i just ran for federal
parliament now oh yeah so that's that's
in quebec yeah it's in quebec so if you
want to go to toronto for instance
if you want to hop on a train i don't
know that it's in effect yet but it's
coming if it's not already in effect
you'll have to show your vaccine
passport to hop on a train what's uh
it's province right what province is
quebec ontario i'm in quebec then
there's ontario then there if you enter
onto ontario there's a border do they do
they check you not anymore they did over
the summer which i found um enraging
politically constitutionally enraging
interprovincial travel which is a
constitutional right under our
constitution um they asked for papers
and they made us register they made us
go back to quebec go online register to
go to new brunswick for a portion of our
road trip that's insane i mean they
brought up blockades literally these
orange uh little freaking
arm guards yeah yeah no no they brought
these like um what are they called um
the orange things that they fill with
water that stands that's uh what
bollards
cones cones no no not the jersey
barriers yes they brought in a whole
bunch of water jersey barriers in
australia banning people from even
crossing the street because there was an
imaginary line between two different
states so
that's scary yeah
you managed to to escape i imagine you
must have crawled through a tunnel
somewhere
actually it was the canadian it was the
u.s border they were very nice three
guys i mean the whole team was very nice
and they looked sympathetic and
understanding to the purpose of my
travels um but yeah i mean i had to show
everything to get across for
non-essential work as of november 8th
borders are going to be open the land
border for non-essential but that means
you're going to have to show proof of
vaccination i think it's 12 or 13 and up
which basically means you know
if you're not vaccinated you're not
traveling when you said that it violates
so you can't
you put it in quotes i have i i'm not
trying to besmirch the canadian
constitution but now i have i've come to
grips with the fact that it seems now
more like a recommendation for the
government is it
the queen's role in that like is it a
recommendation everything it's like you
can they were rights guaranteed by the
charter it's section one these are the
rights guaranteed by the charter they
can only be infringed in as much as is
justifiable in a free and democratic
society and now it seems that in a free
democratic society they can lock you up
in a government quarantine hotel for
three days and make you pay two thousand
dollars for it if you want to leave the
country where there have been
allegations of security guards doing
unspeakable things to women and there's
many ongoing criminal prosecutions right
now of of those guards who are at these
hotels literally opening up the door
when women are by themselves can't have
locks the doors can't have lost yeah the
doors can't have locks and security
guards have assaulted many women in many
of these situations there's been a few
incidents but the quarantine hotels are
no longer in force now for now um but
it's it's nuts the rights that we
thought we had under guaranteed under
the constitution have all been
systematically violated and now the
ultimate irony is that in quebec english
quebecers are complaining that their
linguistic rights are being violated by
francois ago and i said like you guys
just let him lock you in your house
after eight o'clock five months you
think he cares about your language do
you remember spaghetti gate
which one is that that was when in
montreal there was an italian restaurant
that was serving spaghetti and it just
said spaghetti and the language police
came and said why isn't it in french and
they were like
because it's spaghetti and this is an
illustration i don't know about that
case but i had clients who had canned
goods coming in from outside of quebec
that had the ounce abbreviation in
english they had to put on a sticker
that had the ounce of abbreviation in
french that's the language police that's
they called the language police it's uh
office de long francis and their
enforcers the enforcers of the french
language it's a unique province so so so
this is what this is funny because you
brought up that people are angry their
their linguistic rights are being
infringed
is is what's the guy's name francois
lugo is the premier of of the go lego
l-e-g-a-l-u-l-t a-l-u-t legal legal i
can't speak for himself but uh so what
is he doing he's trying to you know make
he's trying to keep franchise like yeah
he's trying to revamp an old law from
1977
called bill 101 which created certain
linguistic protections for the french
language which meant you know french had
to be netmon predominant on public
signage clearly predominant uh and it
applied to businesses of 50 so he's far
right ultra nationalists it's a it's an
it's an ironic thing
i don't know how these measurements work
anymore but right bottom line this bill
96 now it's going to enhance language
laws it's going to cap the amount of
french canadians french quebecers that
can study english in post-secondary
education so this this is how you
protect the language is by crippling
your own population yeah but if the
anglo's complaining about it now i say
you reap what you sow and you should
have been out there on the street doing
viva on the streets complaining about
the curfew for five months but you
weren't because you thought it made you
feel safe and now what's the
justification well the governor doesn't
have a right to do this well and he's
invoking the notwithstanding clause of
the of the constitution which says
you have guaran you have rights and
freedoms that are guaranteed by the
charter except we get to violate them if
we specifically say in the law that we
are violating those rights and if you
don't like it
i sort look it up it's called the not
with standard pause um closed
in french and it basically says if the
government specifically says they're
violating your specific rights certain
rights are
not able to be violated they can invoke
this clause the law can last no longer
than five years or a shorter specified
time the idea being if you don't like a
totalitarian government you'll vote them
out next election but it's it's this is
ridiculous basically cbc says it it's
the uh not attending clause section 33
gives provincial legislature of
parliament the ability through the
passage of law to override certain
portions of the charter for a five-year
term it's great it's great so imagine if
that was like in the u.s they'd be like
we're passing a law that will violate
your second amendment rights because a
constitution allows us to violate your
rights well we kind of have over the
last two years oh he suspended the
constitution pretty much everywhere i
mean we've created a de facto emergency
exception of the constitution which
we've never had it's what well the nazis
to rise to power in germany sure sure
but i think we got to be a little bit
more fair than that it was it was the
famous quote from patrick henry when he
said give me liberty or give me death
unless he's a pandemic or a flu going
around or a flu or a flu or or or if we
go to war in a foreign country and ben
franklin thomas jefferson were like oh
absolutely i mean we we must get
entangled in four we must get stuck in
four entanglements environmental crisis
right well i mean especially i mean this
was our constitution was formed when we
had what seven smallpox epidemics during
that time period yeah i mean so it
wasn't like they were unfamiliar with
the risk they were intimately familiar
with it and decided we should not
forfeit liberty that's that's actually a
good point when people are like george
washington mandated vaccines my response
was like for his conscripts
people who were forced to join the
military sure and uh interestingly they
still guaranteed our rights in a
constitution having dealt with a
smallpox epidemic and didn't include
that as an option going forward which he
could have he could have included a
military exception he did not so the
founders knew exactly what they were
doing and we've just abandoned it over
the last two years this this has been my
biggest learning curve and doing the
live streams with robert the genius of
the constitution the us constitution the
bill of rights i mean it's it's
fantastic and it took foresight and it's
such an understanding
when people first started saying canada
has no freedom of speech they started
telling me this you know back with uh
jordan peterson and compelled speech
like no you guys are wrong we have
freedom of speech here then mike ward
got sentenced to got fined forty three
thousand dollars for making fun of a
handicapped kid jeremy gabriel then i
was like you guys might be right and now
now it's it's on steroids yeah it's
crazy up there man and it's cold yeah
it's cool but the cold is beautiful it's
it's a it's a dry cold as we say it's
not it's not it's not moist i'm
surprised we don't have more radicalized
canadians
because you have like harsh conditions
and oppressive government that's like
there's like a recipe for people to lose
their minds well the people's party what
triple devote though the people's party
tripled the vote nearly a million
canadians who voted of the 16 million
who voted is 800 and some odd thousand
voted for the ppc and then robert you
saw this like after the election
people were asking why would justin
trudeau call an election during a
pandemic it's it's it's a you know
health crisis how can you call an
election
they went after and are still going
after the ppc for a post-election party
that they had where they got the
saskatchewan police to put like the
fbi's most wanted list to post 11
pictures of people who attended an after
party
of the election night and asked for
anonymous tips to identify the uh
[Laughter]
saskatoon i think to actually tweet it
out help us identify these 11
individuals you know
you know i find fascinating is that in
france they riot for everything
but in canada
not nearly as much like what how does it
how does it happen you know because when
you look at here's the way i have to
explain it with with england right you
know the the english they come over they
colonize parts of the new world and we
inherit a lot from these original
settlers people who are willing to risk
everything to come to a new world risk
death to build something with no
guarantees because they wanted freedom
they wanted you know for a variety of
reasons religious freedom or otherwise
the french
came over here as well
but canada is very very different from
you know like france revolts you know
the the yellow jackets when they tried
raising petrol prices the yellow vests
yellow vessels they're going through 15
weeks of protest right now against the
vax mandates
so why why doesn't canada inherit a lot
of a lot of them i don't know and robert
and i have discussed it like even within
canada you would think quebec would be
revolting against this more than perhaps
the rest of canada
crickets
and and it's i think look when you see
people sitting outside on a park bench
double masked reading a book
the media has had its impact now and
people believe they need these measures
in order to feel safe and be safe and
they they've they've passed that point
of no return well canadians always say
sorry all the time so i think that has a
big big thing to do with it but then we
get tom mcdonald and some other good
canadians who don't say sorry seth
rogan's canadian and he's a dick do you
think it has something to do with the
commonwealth and the queen because
australia and canada are getting rocked
right now by this we're not at australia
levels i just think it's like you get to
a point where you feel that there's
nothing you can do to to step it back so
you either are you either are convinced
it's necessary or you're just beaten
into passiveness where you there's
nothing you can do anything like can the
queen just say hey your constitution's
gone now i control it again so the queen
as far as i understand has that's what's
only symbolic that's what they say but
then she can also like dispel she can
get rid of the prime minister if she
wants i don't i don't think so but uh
subject to error nobody likes being
right wrong on the internet
okay
surprise you don't know as a canadian
lawyer and if you want the correct
answer just assert one of them to be
true and you'll get inaudible i get
different information from different
people about the queen's authority in
the commonwealth my understanding is she
has it's symbolic it's purely symbolic
and her face on our money is also purely
symbolic it's not how it works in my
understanding but i know people say that
but no we have our parliamentary system
we make our laws and i don't think the
queen has any do they own a lot of real
estate in canada like in london i was
shocked at how much royal family i don't
properly they own it because megan
couldn't uh couldn't come to she didn't
come to canada so i'm not sure that they
do interesting do you guys see uh what's
going on with canis owens yeah indy 100
australians react to candace owens's
call to for us to invade
over cover restrictions uh and we also
have this
from time
u.s conservatives want to save australia
from cove tyranny australians aren't
interested so the media is running this
claim because candace owens made a joke
where she was like paraphrasing she was
like look how bad it is in australia i
mean when are we deploying obviously i
say that in jest but you know you look
at and so they're like oh publish it
kenneth owens wants to invade australia
this is what this is what happens when
when you have people who believe this
we're a screwed man well and the other
thing about it is there's tons of
complaints in australia but they know
that if they say anything there's some
very prominent personalities other
people we've talked to who've made it
clear they can't talk about australia
publicly even when they're not
physically there because of what might
happen to their friends or their family
back home
it is at that level and i have friends
and other people that i know in
australia and i ask them the question
but i don't trust the answers because i
do genuinely feel that they are afraid
to even speak it on social media and dms
because they know police show up look at
people's homes or facebook posts in
australia only freaking hell no no i'll
shout out avi yamini who is rebel news
uh journalist in australia doing
god's work is an understatement uh it's
it's over the top there they show up to
your house and they they arrest you for
organizing a protest
it was considered to be like the idw
publication when the intellectual dark
web was all big and everything and they
are completely defensive of they are pro
mandate pro lockdown pro camp
and then uh it was mike cernovich he
tweeted out one of these stories like a
video of a guy being indefinitely
quarantined and he was like where's
quillette you'd think a freedom you know
publication would have a lot to write
about
and then someone said something my
response was avi yemeni is you know on
the ground he's covering these stories
so there you go let's call let's call a
spade a spade here what's happening in
australia is tyranny
it's over the top it's draconian it's
it's government literally forcing its
will in the most nastiest disgusting
ways on the people when the people don't
want it there have been major protests
there have been major crackdown against
protests and i think one of the reasons
why politicians in the united states and
journalists in the united states aren't
really talking about it is because they
really want to implement some of the
same policies here in the united states
and you could see that they call for the
same things the same mandates the same
restrictions the same lockdowns and it's
utterly insane now melbourne just a few
days ago announced that they're getting
rid of their lockdowns they had
262 days of stay-at-home orders of
people being locked down not being able
to go outside people were screaming
outside of their balconies just a few
hours ago because they lifted some of
these restrictions and they allowed
people to go out at night so again
what's happening in australia is just
beyond draconian beyond 1984 china's
literally blushing at what australia is
willing to do against their own people
and for that other article to say the
australian people don't want this how do
you know are you are you talking to all
the australian people because there's
sure as hell has been a lot of protests
a lot of people standing up a lot of
people speaking out even though they
face the full might of a technocratic
police state that shows up at their door
because they spread wrong think on the
internet luke the australians don't want
this they don't want liberation and i
know because time magazine says
australian lawmakers took to twitter to
school american critics of the country's
covenanting public health measures that
proves it yes because people because
it's it's it these these lawmakers were
elected by the people that that means
they're they're the will of the people
and the australian people are very happy
that all this is happening what's
extraordinary in the united states and
in most of the western world is how
often they have not utilized the
legislative process how often this has
circumvented the legislative process
circumvented the judicial process who
mostly sort of cowered rather than deal
with it you just had executive orders by
unelected officials who just
basically put us in a real live milgram
experiment let's see how much we can get
away with let's see how much people will
tolerate unfortunately we found out a
lot of people would tolerate much more
than we would like so i i tweeted out
there was a picture of the quarantine
camps i think was in melbourne and
someone said quarantine camp i put
asterisk concentration camp and then it
was some writer from colette or whatever
and then no no it was it was it was
claire lehman herself she was like we
are not building death camps blah blah
blah and i was like well i didn't say
death camp i did say concentration camp
trying to allude to what these things
could be
but then she ends up writing in the
spectator that you know popular american
pundit tim poole says this that and
otherwise and i'm like yo if you really
want to call me out man
like please do so because i would love
to point out how much of a coward claire
lehmann of quillette is and how their
publication are a bunch of cowards and i
will tell you this
i'll say two things if google ever came
to me and said show us your vaccine
documentation or we're deleting your
channel i'd be like
i do nothing
but the issue is this it's um i'm going
to lose my thought again robert it was
the election
i was going to say one more thing
because those are two things the other
thing is
if the united states was was in the
position that australia was in with
camps and permanent lockdown i would be
saying the exact same things i am now i
don't care what the risks are they can
come they can come to my house and they
say you're going on definite quarantine
and
i'm not going to shut up and you gave me
time to think what i was going to say
the media pretends not to understand a
joke when they want to demonize the
person who said it it is clearly a joke
and they pretend that it was a serious
statement and not to bring it back to
the ppc maxine bernier the leader of the
ppc at one point put out a tweet that
said maoists have invaded our government
and are trying to take over
making a joke about how it looks like
you know we're in imitating china mao's
china and canada
the journal or one of the one of the
media ran with it as though he was
seriously saying we're being infiltrated
by communists and the media when it
wants to land base someone pretends that
a joke is not a joke
i think they genuinely don't know what
jokes are i i i mean that literally i'm
not being sarcastic or facetious i
actually don't think they understand
jokes yeah that's mark robert's argument
he argues that stated societies can't
handle comedy it's it's so i tweet
things that are often nonsensical and
they're all taken literally by the left
and i'm just like i so i have a friend
who is i don't know if i'm assuming
we're still friends a very prominent
hollywood personality who told me
messaged me saying you need to
understand that when you tweet these
things there are people who think
they're real and i was like
please
please if that is true and i think it
might be
we are in serious trouble because like
when i post something i posted
president biden as cornholio because he
did the portfolio thing
i said who did this it's so
disrespectful to the president
they're uh you know my favorite was when
i said impeach the queen
so it was like i don't remember exactly
what happened but something happened
with queen elizabeth and i said impeach
queen elizabeth and a website newsguide
certified ran it as fact
personality timpool calls for impeaching
the queen and then i became adamant that
wikipedia include the statement because
it was a reliable source it was
fact-based but yeah in fairness someone
who doesn't know you and doesn't know
your political leanings or your position
might think you're like you're a very
sensitive individual who found it to be
especially no not even no who did this
to joe biden it's it's disrespectful but
um
things get taken literally
on twitter twitter is awesome and then
things if you put in a hashtag sarcasm
everyone's like oh you think your
followers are so stupid they don't know
you're joking yeah so it's a lose lose
have you seen michael mouse's tweets
today
wow
i just tweeted a bunch of i tweet a lot
of just like silly stuff i retweeted
shoe on head she said i effing hate
liberals i don't have any other politics
and that was just fantastic and she did
it because this like liberal guy was
insulting her because she was making fun
of alec baldwin or something
uh i don't know whatever twitter is fun
twitter now i got to go see i'm glad i
put my phone on the floor so i don't get
to go go see michael malus's tweets but
that's next on my wonderful there's so
many memes out there did you see his
tweets
oh my gosh so hot
let me see if i can pull something up
michael you you
troll yeah you you rub scallion
he's just been going off all day it's
been great i've been in i've got to be
able to read at least one so you you
understand like what he's saying but i
don't know if i can i'm trying to find
one
all right um
oh boy okay
i am calling for a total and complete
shutdown of hollywood film production
until our country's representatives can
figure out what is going on hashtag alec
baldwin
that's the one but below it is i'm just
gonna read it script he says in the
culture wars it's currently a draw
between charlottesville and alec baldwin
oh that's brutal that was
brutal
oh my gosh anyway
back to the main point anyway
when you are a rigid ideologue you don't
understand jokes right npc is probably
like the best descriptor for a lot of
these people so like i was saying like i
have a friend who's like you know people
don't realize you're not being serious
with these things and i was like isn't
that really crazy so then i started
tweeting after she told me this i
started posting things on twitter after
i'd say a joke i'd say the above tweet
is not serious i'm told i have to put
this here because people aren't smart
enough to understand
unfortunately that may be reality the
other issue is like
i at some point in time you appreciate
how historically general populations
didn't know of the atrocities that were
going on in their own in their own
countries because of the fact that the
media was being censored and strictly
limited by the government and i i can
wholeheartedly believe that there are
some australians who don't even think
it's that bad in australia right now
because they just don't know and they
don't even know what's going on in their
own country because the media can't
report on it freely even though they
have to walk around with qr codes in
some places to get permission to get
into and now they're implementing one of
the strictest vax passports than
anywhere else in the world where if you
don't comply you can't work in the
public sector in the private sector you
go into a business that you're not
supposed to be in or a business that's
indoor thousands of dollars of fines
levied against you and the business for
just existing as a human being and again
what's happening there there's there's
police officers when people are
gathering for a protest they just opened
fire with less lethal munitions and
rubber bullets right away
they don't even ask any questions
arresting people for walking in nature
by themselves because they weren't
wearing a mask i mean we got to talk
about president cornhole oh yeah we do
so i tweeted this whoever did this
should be ashamed how disrespectful to
our president
so uh here's joe biden with b was his
head and frozen aren't familiar with
what cornholio is on beavers and
butthead one of the best shows ever of
course by mike judge
bevis when he had too much caffeine
would pull his shirt over his head hold
his arms to his side at a 90 degree
angle with fists and he would say he was
the great cornholio joe biden did that
he literally did he literally did it and
i don't know why
but i will say this before we talk about
just joe biden going off of what we're
talking about with twitter and the
silliness there's a reason why i tweeted
whoever did this should be ashamed how
disrespectful to our president it's
because i wanted to share the image
because it's hilarious but i also wanted
to make it so the media had a difficult
time claiming i supported it because
often what they'll do is when i tweet
something out like with the alec baldwin
thing
i said alec baldwin is responsible they
started saying tim poole wants him
arrested and charged and i'm like i
never said any of that stuff i just said
ultimately you know when it comes to
guns you're responsible that's in your
hand so here oh no i was criticizing
this image of joe biden as beavis see
you see you know i just post the image i
don't give a damn yeah but like you know
so look we we uh we've got the zeppelin
coming
um the the famous story you guys
probably don't know everyone else knows
i'm sorry if you hear me tell the story
but for you guys wikipedia claimed
because of some article i invented a
zeppelin that would fly around live
streaming and it was just like insane
because i never did i did work with
drones and so from that i got someone
speculated something wrote about a like
a whiteboard idea we might have had
wikipedia for a year said i invented a
zeppelin
they finally removed it they wouldn't
remove they said i wasn't reliable even
though i said i never invented it and so
uh you know you and i were talking we're
like let's do it so you know ian's been
helping set this project up where we're
actually we have the zeppelin it's
coming it's gonna be here in like a week
or two and then we're gonna
retroactively make wikipedia correct so
i'll have to redo it so i i look at how
the media is fundamentally broken how
they shill for someone like biden and i
understand how they do things why they
do things and understanding how these
these people in the establishment don't
understand jokes you really can just
manipulate their ability to do certain
things so in this instance
it's a tweet of me saying that it's you
should be ashamed for disrupting the
president i would say uh i think the
country would be better off with a
beavis presidency than currently what we
have right now would abide in presidency
that would be my caption but that's hey
that's just me ian what do you think
about president beavis
uh well we would have toilet paper oh
yeah guaranteed
i have a lot of thought i feel like the
reason i haven't been talking is because
i feel like i'm going to be a wet
blanket if i start talking right now i
feel like text is is so dangerous and
can be used as a weapon speech as well
but in this instance we still don't
understand the power of text out of
context especially out of context and
text
if you don't if
satire like you were saying earlier be
careful don't give them any ideas like
if you if you make satire like hey the
the oligarchs are coming for me then
whoa you're putting that out there and
they're gonna be like now's our chance
so that that at me was actually pretty
funny though bieber's beef as president
yeah what uh newsweek said is the
imaginary jetpack
so newsweek wrote an article about the
five strange moments you may you might
have missed the first thing i'll say is
you might have missed it because nobody
watched it the ratings were apparently
like nightmarish i didn't even know what
happened i didn't i didn't either i had
no clue
luke was watching something like some
like army movie or something i was
watching like history of the roman
empire way better which is pretty
amazing you don't even know what he's
doing how does cnn have the authority to
do this given what they've been doing in
terms of putting out garbage news how do
they get the authority to have a town
hall with biden
i don't know and biden wanted to do it
but there's a couple other things too
there was a point where biden said that
corporations aren't paying assent and
then he like made the okay sign and
looked through it and then started
whispering for dramatic effect or
something
there was obviously he said that he
erased colin powell and that colin
powell uh he only he says well i only
won i won only because he was where i
was going to crash into him i think
that's actually an accurate statement
i'd be scared he would crash into me as
well so thank you
he misspeaks on taiwan this one wasn't
that strange but it was kind of funny
biden said if china attacks taiwan we
will intervene and the white house was
like stop don't say that
and then the last one was the last one
he forgets the name of the long beach
port now this
i'm gonna read you this quote and i want
you to take it in
quote
forty percent of all products coming i'm
sorry i'm gonna start over this is from
joe biden and i want it really to sink
in quote
forty percent of all products coming
into the united states of america on the
west coast go through los angeles and
what am i doing here
that's it
what am i doing here
and then cooper interjected not to say
not to press him on his inability to
finish a sentence or properly govern
but to give him the answer because
that's typically what you have the you
know an adversarial media do is what are
the answers for the for the for the
president who can't finish the sentence
what am i doing here you know
what am i saying here where am i going
here that's what he meant i'll give him
the benefit of the doubt if it were the
first i don't i don't i i think the
problem is the media does that so when
joe biden says trinidad shabbat pressure
the media like i'll give you a better
example because that one's silly that
one was pretty good though joe biden
will say something like
we you know uh americans
we gotta come on you know we gotta uh
raise taxes on the one percent and the
media will say joe biden said to raise
taxes on the one percent they won't show
you that he struggled to speak he said
it he stammered they'll put quotes in
place and they'll put we dot dot
americans dot dot need to tax dot dot
the one percent dot dot because i have
to cut out all of the things where he's
screwing up if the dude literally says
what am i doing here that's not
something you normally say you'd go like
this
here's what i'd say
40 of all products coming into the u.s
on the west coast uh west coast go
through la and uh what's the other one
long beach they go through long beach i
wouldn't i wouldn't go what what am i
doing here
now if you're a senile old man yeah
you'd say what am i doing here and then
i got to tell you if if if that were me
with biden cooper interjected is it long
beach long beach thank you i respond
with oh mr president you're you're on
television live doing a town hall
is everything all right whatever state
he's in the first state if it were the
first fifth tenth time but it's
systematic and it is it is uh you can't
ignore it it's it's out there and
everybody knows it's just nobody's
talking about it i mean we talk about it
this is a funny thing you guys see the
clip with barry weiss on c on cnn with
brian seltzer of course
you see that so barry weiss she's doing
she's been doing a pretty good job i
would say she's been doing a pretty
great job actually calling out the stuff
and she was on cnn and she was like look
at all the stuff that's going on with
crt in schools and we can't talk about
it we're not allowed and then brian's
author's like what do you mean not
allowed people talk about it all the
time and it's like no brian you don't
you never talk about it you lie you get
in the periphery you ignore it he gave
10 seconds to andy know when andy noe
got beaten by antifa because he had to
he didn't do a segment on the on the on
the dangerous journalists face so no
people don't talk about it well no i
mean a classic example of this is the
cal written house case so people who've
seen the video know the facts know he's
innocent however if you talk to the
average kenosha juror they don't know
that 60 of them presume he's guilty and
the reason why they presume he's guilty
is because of mainstream media it's why
we have to go through an extensive jury
selection process in two weeks just to
get what he's constitutionally entitled
to a presumed instant jury we got this
tweet great tweet paul paul begala
that sound you hear is the shattering of
the right wing myth about potus not
being sharp his wit command of details
personal engagement are impressive he's
clearly on the top of his game not even
recommending that folks inject bleach
but now here's here's the thing i read
this not knowing who this guy was i
would think this was satire if i did not
know it's not the baby yo i know paul
gail i mean we talked i worked in the
clinton white house in the summer of
1993. but gallery used to be an
old-school populist he used to be
indistinguishable from steve bannon wow
he got a lot of money became a corporate
corporate you know well whatever
language you can use on youtube yes
so trump never told people to inject
bleach
yeah of course not it was all nonsense i
mean it was a ridiculous uh exaggeration
now partially trump could have handled
aspects of that better but it's just
they need to live in their own world to
such a degree they have to now create
their own world and it's going to
backfire over time i got a little flack
for being a little critical of trump on
that video where i said when his excuse
was that it was sarcasm was probably not
the right word for what he was intending
to do there right yeah but um i swear to
you that could be as easily parody as
seriousness could you could you click on
his uh profile so he could read the um
bios and uh he doesn't know
he's not gonna let me know he used to be
uh james carville's partner okay back in
the day oh did he really oh yeah he
helped harris wofford win in 1991 235
000 followers author if you're fired the
perfect guide to beating donald trump
cnn contributor counselor for president
clinton dopey flunky according to trump
oh well yes that's true he is now dope
so i i look
joe biden's town hall he started his
profile picture he stuttered he
stammered he was all over the place he
voted i know i i i know who he is but
he's vaccinated too biden did not come
off as strong
the the cornholio thing was weird enough
it was very weird because i thought i
thought someone froze framed it freeze
frame right and i didn't realize the
video was still running i think he may
have been seizing or having a stroke ooh
so that's why that's why rogan said
there's no way he took the actual shot
because they're like you watch this guy
you want to give him a shot and you want
to see what what he might do how he
might react online well there's a number
of reasons why i don't think he took the
shot and i agree with rogan it's because
there's too much risk if he actually did
because there are people who have
adverse reactions to it there are people
who do take it and pass out so so if
you're at the white house pr and when
you have yeah if you're doing the white
house pr be like okay give them the shot
later maybe but give them some give them
some fake shots because the risk the
risk is too overwhelming for them to
take and they would never take that risk
i get the idea i just disagree i think
the simple solution tend to be the
correct one joe biden was on a sound
stage they controlled the feed they
could have given them the shot and then
they could they just turn it off
afterwards anyway
but there was journalists there right oh
come on in the room yeah a lot of them
would have covered it up journalists
having heard both sorry sorry the
government establishment repeaters that
regurgitate all the diarrhea and hot
trash that the government gives them
yeah now i was learning about caligula
today he's the mad emperor
in the roman
empire and he suffered a brain injury
but before his brain injury he was
actually known as a really great emperor
as a really great leader a people person
who gave the people what they wanted was
very diplomatic was very smart then he
had this weird brain injury and then he
went crazy he went mad he went through
he made his horse really exactly he went
through
he did a lot of things we came and
mentioned on this show if this was a
family-friendly show but but he had
cognitive decline and utterly created
chaos throughout the entire roman empire
which and as as i'm watching this as i'm
learning this i'm like holy cow now we
have a presidency that clearly the
president is going through a major
cognitive decline
clearly the man has two brain stints
inside of his head right now as we're
speaking clearly he's not all there and
we have utter chaos all around us we
gotta we gotta we gotta we gotta keep
the focus on cnn my friends oh yeah
check this one out
joe rogan calls cnn's don lemon a dumb
mother
for doubling down on a horse dewormer
narrative saying you can't allow these
you can't allow people to say things
that are absolutely untrue when you have
an effing news organization rogan said
well joe
is punching buddy
don lemon doubled down and claimed that
you did in fact ingest horsteam or
dewormer which is a lie
and um you thought that was bad
cnn
tripled down
cnn defends joe rogan treatment in fiery
statement eric wemple of the washington
post accurately points out cnn
is acting more like an advocacy group
than an actual news organization he says
this cnn's statement sounds more like
the work of an advocacy group than a
journalism outfit the issue actually
begins and ends the integrity of cnn's
content he says if we take rogan's
prescription claim at face value and cnn
hasn't challenged it the network's
coverage was slanted in some cases and
straight up incorrect than others
here's their quote
cnn says the heart of this debate has
been purposefully confused and
ultimately lost it's never been about
livestock versus human dosage of mectin
the issue is that a powerful voice in
the media who by example and through his
platform so doubt in the proven and
approved science of vaccines while
promoting the use of an unproven
treatment for covet-19 a drug developed
to ward off parasites and farm animals
the only thing cnn did wrong here was
bruise the ego of a popular podcaster
who pushed dangerous conspiracy theories
and risked the lives of millions of
people in doing so joe
sitting before me are two wonderful
lawyers yes
please can we would you
give him some advice on suing the pants
off cnn please please please i mean be
careful what you say about don lemon
because i'm currently suing him for
sexual assault of a bartender dustin
heist wow i mean he is incredibly
accused uh the harvey weinstein of uh of
the media wow and uh and he has so far
dodged an evaded responsibility and
accountability we'll see if that happens
come trial in january but joe clearly
has a very good claim i mean this is
repeated libel and they're clearly just
going to accelerate and they're going to
keep doing it and i hope he does take
action i know in the past he's been
reluctant but at some point he has to
for the benefit of everyone else because
if joe rogan sits there and takes it
other people will think they don't have
a fighting chance how would he do it
what would he what would he do hire just
find a lot of contact just file suit and
file uh joe has plenty of good lawyers
but uh so all he's gonna do is file a
libel suit file right there in the
western district of texas and in the
austin division where he now resides and
file it against cnn and go after them i
mean the anti-slap statute doesn't apply
there so he doesn't have to worry about
fees you have don lemon not donald i'm
sorry sanjay gupta on his own podcasting
cnn shouldn't have done it what do they
do after that they do it two more times
so i want to say one thing washington
comp washington post calling cnn
activist journalism is the
kettle black but at the very least they
got it right here um but robert someone
in the comments section of our last
highlight said what would his damages be
he hasn't sustained any damages so what
would well i mean that'd be up to the
jury to determine but i mean at a
minimum he could get a factual finding
that cnn lied about and that has value
and utility right out of the gate and
also discovery should be extremely
interesting to how they decided to say
it's horse medicine when a doctor
prescribed it to him when i brought suit
for all the covington kids uh the goal
was to stop and prevent them from
telling these kind of lies because
typically ordinary people can't fight
back joe can fight back and that's why
he should fight back for the people who
cannot fight back joe can write a check
to a law firm and completely forget
about it absolutely and then he'll get
an email saying hey joe here's the
update here's what they said you know
sign off here if you agree here's what
we're going to respond with and i'll go
you got it
i mean it was patent libel they said
that he took something he didn't take
and they knew well a lot but your point
was sanjay gupta is even better
they said he took something he didn't
take their chief medical correspondent
said they are wrong and then they said
it again they shouldn't have done that
joe why didn't you press him i don't
know and then they do this afterwards
that's come on it's a slam dunk
and then they purport that he's the one
who's in the wrong for being offended by
their libel i mean it's it's nuts sanjay
gupta went on a show and said he there
yeah we lied we messed up we got this
one wrong and now they're like he they
had him on i mean i don't wanna i don't
even wanna think what they did to him in
the backstage um when they brought in
sanjay gupta for that screw-up and now
he had to go on national television and
then go back on what he said on the on
the rogan podcast i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna reveal to you guys see i was
i was actually going to hire joe rogan
for one billion dollars
um but once i found out i took horse
medicine i had to cancel that deal
sorry joe that's a billion dollars in
damages uh well he probably does have
some damages claims because they're
gonna be some people who don't listen to
him and some limitation on his ratings
and given the scale that he's at it
doesn't take long to get to 10 million
plus and we know cnn wrote at least some
sizable check to nicholas sandman when
they were caught lying to him they're
currently facing a major lawsuit from
project veritas for lying about project
veritas and james o'keefe so uh but
rogan would put them at the most
exposure mostly in the court of public
opinion but financially as well do you
guys see the the netflix thing the
netflix protest yes yes yes so this this
guy his name is vito i think right yeah
the competition yeah they attacked him
they tore a sign apart said he had a
weapon after they said he threw his
friend down on the floor that hit his
head well that was and that was that was
this dick masterson yeah he's a comedian
he's a podcaster he's well known yeah so
they attack these people the crazy thing
was the ap took a photo of this guy veto
when he was saying something like black
lives matter agreeing with him and they
said that he was like the aggressor who
was clashing or attacking and because it
was an ap stock photo every outlet that
picked it up shared the same false uh
caption wow yeah which is liable i mean
that's exactly what the covington kid
knows well here's my question if uh uh
if one of these outlets uses an ap
source that says it is are they
responsible yes they are uh every
publisher any single publishers
absolutely every single one you guys
should hit up veto sounds great yeah
exactly well i mean i mean all of them i
mean there's so many credible suits but
i think the utility for rogan is this is
cnn and this is the context of covet
coverage right and this is critical and
essential that they let it let the court
fully determine who told the truth and
who's been lying and that has value to
everybody would there be any relevance
in uh real life damages with people who
listen to this propaganda and say that
they had you know parasites and and they
couldn't you know use it very difficult
now the left has been pursuing those
theories in a wide range of other cases
but uh normally that would be too uh
distant in order to get damages the
amazing thing is my underlying belief in
all of this is they didn't run with the
dewormer story because they believed
anybody believed it they wanted to
create the hype so they could go get
some people out there who don't really
get good news to go take dewormer the
the veterinary application not the human
so they could then say look people
actually did it after we spent two weeks
hyping it up well so uh one one thing
that was pointed out by a lot of people
which is a good point is that by cnn
coming out and saying joe rogan took
horse paste and then joe rogan coming
out and saying the medication worked
people are going to believe the tractor
supply stuff
and that's cnn's fault
joe also got monoclonal antibodies the
emergency use authorization approved by
the fda
that
ron desantis was trying to get because
they've been using it in florida
seems like that stuff really works and
it's approved treatment well it's what
the biden administration tried to take
away from florida and
they did yeah no no but according to ron
desantis he fought against this and this
is one reason why florida's cases are so
down right now as they are you look at
the new york cases they're double that
of florida right now and you see their
policies you see the the what kind of
restrictions they implemented the exact
opposite of what new york did so there's
a
there deserves to be a bigger
conversation about these two different
approaches new york and florida because
it's pretty clear what's happening
talk to your doctor
i i gotta wonder is the only missing
piece here uh uh uh a definitive damage
because
if if if cnn lies
sanjay gupta says yes joe they lied
i mean that's clear admission right he
said they shouldn't have done it but it
would be the damn you can get a
declaratory judgment like robert
suggested during our last live stream uh
nominal damages
and in reality he's got at least 10
million yeah he could get an expert to
say he's got 10 million damages that's
just realistic because of the scale that
he operates he never actually said that
it was the eye word the ivormectin that
the horse dewormer that made him better
he never even promoted any of it he just
said this is what i'm all my doctors
gave it to me three days later he said i
feel better my uh you know test is now
showing i'm negative never even credited
to any one element of what he was taking
he was on a strict regiment of stuff
prescribed by a doctor plus rogan also
says that uh they they changed the way
that he looked they they used the filter
to make him look a lot sicker than he
was from his original instructions
so is there is there a possibility to
even pursue that legally is that is that
an option well that could be pursued and
then you throw in that the fda
piggybacked off of this the fda put out
that fake tweak that gupta was talking
about
that was deliberately missed and this is
i'm suing the fda right now for their
bait and switch on what they did with
the vaccine they lie they right now have
military surgeons and military doctors
going in and faking labels to try to
convince people that they're getting
something different than what
so what it is is you have currently the
only thing that's available is the eua
so the emergency use authorized under
the under the law you can't uh force
that there's an informed consent
requirement that's the nuremberg code
put into law
so but and what the defense secretary
said is the only thing we're going to
require is the approved the fda biologic
licensed one not any of the eu a ones
exactly but it's not available and if
pfizer has said they're not going to be
producing it for months
so some smart soldiers we brought to it
against the fda saying they shouldn't
have licensed uh coma uh kubernates as
long as it was uh unavailable does that
pronounce it
i i don't even know what happened
but it it's supposed to be like mrna in
between and then covet at the beginning
and whatever at the end
it's like quasi-exactly i think they
make it confusing uh deliberately
completely too much like comorbidity
which is what i didn't like yesterday
but here's my question the fda has said
that they are interchangeable in the
same formulation they have and they
haven't so what they said is they said
it's medically interchangeable in ways
that don't impact safety and efficacy
however that's really misleading because
under the eua approvals you do not have
to comply with good manufacturing
policies under the eua policy procedures
you have a whole different liability
you're completely immune everybody's
completely immune right once it shifts
to a la a licensed product it has to go
through a different manufacturing
process it has to meet good
manufacturing policies it has to be
distributed in a certain way
and it actually is medically different
they claim it won't impact safety and
efficacy but that's mostly speculative
and last but not least it has a whole
different legal liability risk and by
law cannot be compelled and yet what you
have is the defense department
misleading their own soldiers to the
degree they're mislabeling a drug that's
not even available according to the
fda's office and the mainstream media is
running with headlines approved by the
fda safe and effective 100 percent dr
fauci safe and effective
technically the truth the uh pfizer did
get a vaccine approved by the fda
exactly exactly but they don't tell you
everything else
yeah they would say because it's the
pfizer vaccine people assume the pfizer
biotech is the exact same exactly so i
read that it said it was it was
interchangeable
medically interchangeable as to safety
and efficacy but even that's misleading
that's why we sued him we shoot him in
the eastern district of tennessee and
have a hearing in two weeks about it
because what's the what's the has
anything happened uh yeah the government
filed their opposition we filed our
reply the judge is going to have a
hearing first week in november so what
so if the media is the one lying though
what's your claim like what's oh no it's
the fda lied because the fda misled
everybody they buried in the footnotes
the truth they knew legally they could
not issue a biologic licensed approval
until unless they revoked the emergency
use authorized drugs as required by law
and they chose not to do so in order to
force the mandates on people in
violation of the nuremberg code
they don't even deny that functionally
they just claim we can't sue they claim
nobody can sue them so let's so you're
having a hearing in two weeks yep let's
uh let's let's go to the uh we'll we'll
hear about that oh yeah we'll get the
update but i want to use this
opportunity to talk about you know i
think we're getting into the territory
where everything's going absolutely
insane and so we have this tweet here
which exemplifies it and makes me very
happy
rachel bay says the officials who
represent maryland's three westernmost
counties in the general assembly have
asked if their counties can join west
virginia yes so a lot of people don't
know this
west virginia and virginia were one
state
then the civil war happened and west
virginia and virginia went bye-bye west
virginia said we think slavery is bad
we're with the north we want to stay in
the union virginia said we're going to
be the capital of the confederacy right
now we're starting to see it's getting
so bad politically especially with the
story you're telling about the fda and
and the risks we have the censorship the
media
we operate right now
uh this studio is in one of these
counties i am very excited to hear that
this is happening we have these two
letters first
this is from speaker roger hanshaw and
president craig blair it says speaker
handshawn president blair arts to them
sorry
we the undersigned state representatives
for garrett and allegheny counties in
the state of maryland request that you
consider adding us as constituent
counties to the state of west virginia
we believe this arrangement may be
mutually beneficial for both states and
for our local constituencies please
advise on next steps
and then i love this one speaker
henshawn president blair we the
undersigned state representatives for
washington county and the state of
maryland also request you consider
adding washington county as a
constituent county to the state of west
virginia we believe this arrangement may
be mutually beneficial for both states
and for our local constituencies please
advise on next steps uh i live in west
virginia
because it's a tri-state you know we
shop sometimes in virginia we go for
dinner i live in in west virginia but we
work in maryland so we're just between
all three um
delegate mike mckay and delegate william
will
we are here as your our eager
constituents wanting to help in any way
possible to allow us to join with west
virginia
look so west virginia i live there i'm a
resident i have constitutional carry
it's fantastic it's way better
maryland is western maryland where we
are it's effectively west virginia if
you ask anybody around here there's a
guy who lives over here he's got these
massive signs that say like swamp 40
miles that way
says bring your boots amazing sign by
the way and uh the people here would
love it to not be under the boot of
baltimore oh yeah culturally socially
economically politically i mean they're
right in the middle of the place that
triggered the last civil war i mean
harper's ferry sits right on the battle
they all owe john brown so the uh so it
makes sense and what has to happen is
the maryland wisconsin i'm sorry west
virginia maryland legislatures have to
approve and then congress has to approve
never going to happen probably not but
maybe because if you're maryland do you
really want western maryland if you're
the democrats in baltimore you probably
would love to jettison them yeah west
virginia why not add your territory add
some tax base you'll get a democrat
governor every every time if you get rid
of western uh the only thing is probably
they would look at congressional
representation would it give west
virginia enough to add back their third
seat that they lost yeah no they didn't
hypothetically this ever happens what's
the time frame how long would that be it
can happen quickly you know it requires
both legislators in congress it can
happen with i mean the old days they
used to approve states within weeks
within months
so what do we what do we what do we have
to do to encourage this
that's a good question i mean the i mean
i wouldn't encourage anything you know
that uh uh too provocative well look
this is this is just people saying
we don't get we know we're not like the
people of dc in baltimore we're more
like west virginia so we'll just
convince the people in dc and baltimore
that uh western maryland is really
holding them back and they just need to
jettison them and give them to west
virginia it's a good point you don't
want to have these maggots you know
voting in your elections yeah maryland's
got a republican governor exactly it
would be a democratic governor if they
would just let these counties go that's
right
but i don't think they would it's a lot
like what's happening in oregon you know
the eastern oregon counties are also oh
they went out they voted right they
voted two eastern washington once out
they would like to join greater idaho
make idaho like a true idaho you know
it's funny having grown up my whole life
in a city and then lived in new york and
then ultimately just being like it's
better to not live in these cities
because they're insane yeah it is funny
i drove through new york to get here had
coffee with my best friend in new york
and it was i know my frame of the world
has changed with what's happened in the
last two years but it was the first time
i really appreciated i forget who said
it that living in a big city is like
prisoners sort of um
learning to love their imprisonment and
you know we're in new york i see people
in the park playing violin i see people
everyone's talking everyone's trying to
make the best of life in new york but it
was the first time that it really felt
like the city was too much it looked
like people were just trying to make the
best of their living but that people
didn't really love it anymore but that
might have been a lot a lot of
projection coming from me
did you stop in new york city yeah new
york city property it was in the lower
east side i grew up in new york did you
need to present your papers to get that
coffee i did no i didn't because we
drank it outside um
everybody i said on my channel i'm i'm i
got both shots everyone knows because
i've crossed the border but i i refuse i
mean except for bowling with my kids
where's the camera that i have to
apologize to again except for bowling
with my kids that one day
i i refuse to do it but do you don't eat
down anymore would you have like a card
no i have a picture of my paper uh
literally the funny thing is after i got
my second shot i took a picture of the
paper they printed at the pharmacy sent
it to my wife with a very funny joke
like ha ha the papers wouldn't they ask
and i became it became a very funny
email that i sent to my wife because
they literally when we were traveling
new brunswick they like show me your
papers i had only had one shot at the
time and i was like man they're gonna
they're gonna tell me i can't go on a
family vacation now that's ridiculous
it's so draconian this is the crazy
thing to me i mean and that would work
in new york city it's working it's
working everybody every sign said you
want to sit down indoors vaccines no i
mean i mean the fact that you've got a
picture of a piece of paper
and that's like okay so what's stopping
people from you know oh there's massive
already in new york i
have had i mean i will never do it
because i don't trust it not to get
hacked in terms of like this close to
the authorities but there's people i
know people who are who are providing
personally i know nobody i have no idea
yeah i want to take it back i know
nobody but like i said but there's a
high probability that there are a lot of
these people and that's why these
numbers of how many people actually took
this or have this should be questioned i
don't represent themselves you know just
what what if someone like went to mexico
and then just went to a doctor well
that's the key is that you get
international that's what they can't
control that's what there's no u.s
tracking for that's why ultimately the
goal is to have international tracking
you know have a little chip in your body
that everybody can be universal already
got a chip in your passport the world
economic forum called for a global
passport system of of medical records
that keep you up to date with your
status and your tests that will be uh
used with uh in you know internationally
with all the countries being synced in
into the same system that's literally
what they were just talking about months
ago so yeah this has been
very long part of your financial system
that's why they're talking about fed
coin that's going to be part of your
identification yeah the bank of england
the bank of england is literally talking
about building a cryptocurrency that's
centralized controlled by them just
after a few days ago one of their
spokespersons said that bitcoin's going
to destroy the financial markets as
they're calling for their own bitcoin
that's that's fed coin controlled by
them at everything imagine the control
they could cut off your ability to buy
gas buy food do anything and that's
literally their plan that's the social
credit score it's already exist in china
and there's plans to implement it here
in the united states through the vaccine
mandate through the vaccine passports
it's a social credit score uh in a
trojan horse they'll experiment on
canada first well and i just don't
understand the the rationale behind the
vaccine passport you can go in order
your coffee then leave but you can't sit
down in there to drink your coffee as if
and as if the double vaccination is the
criteria that's the most relevant and
not if you're worried about transmission
yeah a negative test but it's it's nuts
uh but people are putting up with it in
canada in new york there's a little more
defiance so so i can explain it it's
actually quite simple um
but so if if you walk into a restaurant
you need to wear your mask because
for people uh you know walking around
the the kova is at head level but when
you sit down now you can take your mask
off and it's okay now however
if you're not vaccinated actually
inverts you're okay standing up walking
in
but sitting down is when you get
problems no no not anymore they change
that rule you have to even if you're
vaccinated still wear the masks and in
australia this virus usually goes to
sleep at around 8 p.m when the
government says that there's a curfew so
that's what it's and
it's also a super spreader event when
it's when it comes to republican protest
but it's it's something that heals
people during leftist black lives matter
protests
at 8 pm is when it's most active that's
why everyone has to stay home unless
you're joe biden and then you don't even
have to wear the mask when you go into a
high-end restaurant well everybody knows
that joe biden is is the healthiest
president i've ever had exactly exactly
very much that is a fiddle yeah yeah
i'll all one-up the insanity did i talk
about the
isolating kids in canada no
we we got an email from school i did a
video on this because i didn't believe
it was true where out of ontario they
were saying if a kid came in contact
with someone who tested positive that
kid has to isolate and then you saw
people tweeting online my kids crying in
the bedroom i'm slipping food under the
door
oh i saw that that's so bad now i don't
know if i believe those tweets because
you have to be a little skeptical
but then we in our community got a
recommendation
kids and eight-year-old kids in a class
came in contact with the kid who tested
positive all kids were asymptomatic
if they were even infected but they
tested negative no symptoms negative
tests had to isolate for 10 days and i
expressed some discontent with the
government policy say this is idiotic
and then a total coincidence the next
day they the government issues a
correction no longer need to isolate an
eight-year-old kid who's
tested negative with no symptoms it's it
is i don't know what they're doing like
there's that guy awakened with jp who
puts out some good videos this is what
we do today throw something on the wall
that's going to be the criteria the
problem with all these vaccine mandates
all of them are about asymptomatic risk
there is no real risk the only risk the
only limitation the vaccine main date
lawsuits that they should expand upon is
asymptomatic risk is not a meaningful
risk of sp offspread and that's the only
thing the vaccine purports to solve and
it doesn't solve its own admission
allegedly again and then all the data
should be questioned because all the
data is coming from pfizer and pfizer
has been caught fudging the data fudging
the trials and kicking people out of
trials that get sick from the vaccine
like that 12 year old that ended up in a
wheelchair and then she was a part of
the trial group and when the trial group
the report came out she wasn't a part of
it i can't go into details but there'll
be a big whistleblower coming out on
that precise topic in the next it's
crazy what's happening we got to be
careful with anecdotes yeah absolutely
as far as oh no i represent a
whistleblower it will be no that's
different that's that's true i just mean
like you know um
my my concern is you know someone will
see a story and they'll say this proves
my view of the situation and i'm like
there's tons of that of course
causation correlation anecdotes prove
nothing except that you have you have an
example but um i just love the fact that
everybody now trusts pfizer
who paid a 2.3 bill 2.3 billion they
trust merck who paid however much for
their for for johnson johnson
and and they trust the government a
little baby
in canada the government just apologized
for its horrible treatment of the
indigenous with its residential schools
we did it for their own good at the time
or we said we did yes we you know we
knew they were dying we hid it now we
apologize for it trust us today did you
guys hear this johnson johnson thing
apparently i think it's the talcum
powder right they are they're separating
it off into a they're spinning off a new
company and bankrupting it so they don't
have to pay a settlement exactly it's
it's hilarious to see that in leftist
subreddits where they're like evil
corporation but then also like haha
mangas are dumb for not getting
vaccinated yes it's atrocious completely
and in the cases that they're citing are
the cases that were used for eugenics in
the in the 19th and 20th century so it's
very dangerous what's happening legally
politically across the board uh people
you know i want to i want to stress this
point too because people often say we
when we had michael schoelenberg for
instance he's like what what
what about when people say we've had
other mandates like mmr and stuff and
i'm like i've never been required to get
a vaccine to go to 7-eleven before
exactly not only that there's always
been religious accommodations for all
those children child vaccines there's
always been medical accommodations
there's always been prior immunity
accommodations so we've never had it and
again those as you know we're limited to
kids for public education for which you
could opt out so it's a completely
unanalogous comparison that a lot of
these people are using the virus itself
is not analogous either because
measles must umbrella actually pose a
meaningful risk for kids this we're
talking now in canada
compelled vaccination of five to 11 year
olds for in canada 300 000 some odd
cases 1500 hospitalizations 15 deaths
and we just found out two weeks ago at
the very least on this occasion a death
day reported in a 14 year old attributed
to covid the sister came out and said
the kid had stage four brain cancer was
hospitalized in a coma and they did a
test on the kid but the there's two
words here vaccine mandate and the most
important is mandate
like university of denver saying flu
vaccines this is i think just a the
bigger issue i think is they want to get
people to mandate they want to get to
the point where you have the app where
they can start mandating many many more
things than just vaccination they can
mandate any kind of medical property go
back to the eugenics era right the whole
goal was to establish the state's power
and the corporate power over the human
body that they control you you don't
control yourself once they establish
that legal precedent we know where it
leads because they gave us for
sterilization and forced attention camps
based on ancestry and then ultimately
the nazis and there's a lot of really
messed up stuff happening in the early
1900s and that's what and when they cite
those cases i'm like do you recognize
you're citing the same supreme court
that said racial segregation was a good
idea well to be to be fair though derek
bell agreed with plessy versus ferguson
and uh he's like a hero to the locusts
so yeah i mean the levels of insanity i
mean it's the professional class has too
much power that's the problem let's go
to super chats my friends if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to the channel become a member at
timcast.com now let's read what people
are saying that went by so quick yeah i
was like it's 9 30. it's 9 30 already
like no i got so much i want to say
and i want to hear from you guys so much
about so much more about the lawsuits
i'm like oh man everyone should look
into the story coming out of canada that
are the health
minister whatever chief medical officer
of alberta dina hinshaw she apologized
for
erroneously describing the death of that
14 year old kid to covid when it was
stage 4 brain cancer wow and she said
causing the family additional grief this
was after some public outcry yeah but if
they've done it once i just want to know
how many times they've done it before
yeah absolutely all right we got the
meaning of nerd he says hey tim on my
channel i analyze pop culture shows and
movies and derive a more meaningful and
liberty loving message for my audience
from it i thought of analyzing your song
can i get permission to use the song in
the background or will i get copyright
um i don't believe you will youtube has
an automated system though but people
have done it before i i won't
issue anything though that's for sure
you should change the license on the
song because otherwise just your well i
guess your word is binding if you do it
on video like that i'm not going to
issue a strike against anybody for using
it i said the other day by all means
download it share it put it on you go
into the setting on the on the video
also available
amazon that's right
all right let's see we got here
hey abbott says never forget the four
basic rules of for firearm safety if you
follow them every time you'll be safe mr
baldwin managed to break all of those
rules at once and this is what happens
is the ak guy gonna visit the compound
uh yeah brandon herrera um working on it
yeah definitely that'd be awesome he's
an awesome youtuber
all right let's see we got
john clark says f for viva direct from
ottawa and trudeau for tim
yeah f is an inside joke it means i'm
late when i'm never late except that one
time i was late
a lot of people are cheering for viva
and barnes
diver says let's go brandon
i think they have a let's go true to
also now at this point
i love it some dip nag says aviva barnes
and tim fool podcast this must be the
best timeline
tim fool huh
you got me
original jack sparrow says just take my
money all right okay ethan randall says
to viva f
you do that to us too yeah we're not
late i love it but the dedication it
takes for someone to give a super chat
for one letter congratulations i
appreciate that wayne smith says alec
baldwin has killed more people than all
of the january 6 protesters combined
that's what i'm saying
yikes man wow
cliff lee viva how are you able to
escape canada thought you were
incarcerated there
it was a very look coming out was easy
going back i think it's going to be
harder than coming to the states
interesting even though you're going
back to your home country and i say what
what happens if i don't have a pcr test
how is my government going to keep me
out of my own country
but uh look i'll get back those devices
does the government check or does the
airline checks because i drove okay i
drove because the border patrol checks
yeah because in the united states if you
come into the united states as an
american citizen you have to show a
negative test to the airline not at
customs this would have been the case
for flying and now i have to show
apparently a pcr to come in through the
land border um but it won't be a problem
but it's just it's it it increases and
positive vaccine status if you're a
victim i don't know about the positive
vaccines yeah but i know as of november
8th yeah if you want to visit canada now
you have to be fully vaccinated
all right i'm gonna read it do it alex
ryan says tim watch biden again his
clenched fists and vacant stare are
signs that he's pooping himself oh
anyone who's had or attended two kids
can recognize the signs that's actually
a good point i've seen that yes yeah
they
i will go back and look very thoroughly
because that's that interesting theory i
bet he's got like
tier 5
2020 model elite ultra men's you know
technical
evaporating diapers that's right yeah
yeah so it's a portal yeah it's a portal
just goes right into the sewer that's
right
nathan dolan says have viva and barnes
explain rights to ian
oh
civil rights versus natural rights i
mean really civil rights origin and
justification can be natural rights it
depends on your perspective as to what
justifies it technically what civil
rights are in the legal system is it
comes from the constitution or it comes
from a statute or it comes from the
common law but the the question is where
does that where's the moral authority
for the constitution civil rights the
statutes civil rights the common laws
civil rights come from some would argue
i would argue natural law natural law
and the idea that uh you if you're
religious god put sort of imprinted upon
us the uh our conscience and our
cognitive capacity the recognition of
certain universal moral truth which by
the way informed consent used to be one
we called it just cogens in the
international law we executed people for
violating informed consent that's what
the nuremberg trials were about we said
these rules are so universal there's a
classic example so universal there was
no informed consent law in the german
statutes in the german constitution so
how did we execute people afterwards for
violating it we said that's such a
universal recognized law that no
civilized society anywhere can violate
and are natural rights and human or
natural law and human rights are those
synonymous is there human rights and
civil rights they can be so many people
would say our human rights derive from
natural law some people don't agree with
natural law being the basis of it so you
could have a philosophical disagreement
as to the
moral justification
of or authorization for civil rights but
it is for many people the same we go
through sometimes we talk about human
rights and civil rights and that they're
i do you see those as different no i
mean i see civil rights as expression of
human rights but civil rights don't
always capture all the human rights that
exist hence martin luther king's protest
and his letter from birmingham jail
i have a shorter answer in canada no
rights privileges
i'm being tongue-in-cheek so the
argument we had was that um i think luke
you were here for this right or no
what was happening it was jack murphy um
ian said that rights are culture-based
and that you're effectively granted them
by the constitution and the uh my
argument i think jack murphy is that the
rights are inalienable they're they're
intrinsic to you based on several
factors and there's
there's big moral questions
philosophical questions but the general
idea is
saying that our rights come from god
doesn't necessarily mean you have to be
theistic it's just like the rights exist
within us no matter what a government
can infringe our rights right but the
rights are always ours and ian disagrees
if a culture doesn't agree with it
you're right yeah i think i was defining
civil rights and you were defining
natural rights or human rights it's uh
well you know if you want to define
civil rights as what a particular
culture defines but it doesn't have to
be so for many people civil rights are
just an expression of natural rights it
doesn't have to be an either war so it's
whether or not you believe civil rights
are rooted in natural rights is the
where the debate tends to occur does
that make sense
yeah i mean if we if if the culture
thinks it's okay to eat baby hearts then
you have a natural right to eat baby
hearts no no because i the natural
rights would be objective moral truths
if you believe in a certain form of
natural law i believe that these uh the
they transcend culture right i think if
you're the culture that's deciding what
transcends the culture then you always
have some degree of that yes that that
would be my brother gordon barnes uh
debate so he would that would be his
extensive he would he does classes on
exactly that in his philosophy classes
all right well let's just read some more
super chats not spend too much time on
one idea mima type says you've been
talking about how it's important to
create culture outside of a leftist
frame check out the foundation for
economic education my friend sean malone
has a youtube series there analyzing
movies from a liberty angle i think he'd
be a great guest for your show doesn't
sheamus do stuff with them yeah freedom
tunes yeah what's your name sorry oh
yeah that stuff is good that's great
that's the best stuff yeah freedom tunes
is fantastic they might be recommended
they're
tomorrow too i think yeah maybe look all
right our interview
one of our brief interviews with sticks
hexen hammer they produced
it's phenomenal yeah they did cool
ken davis says every handgun is loaded
that is correct
we have a whole lot of people saying yay
viva and barnes yes
josiah magnuson says you miss 100 of the
shots you don't take alec baldwin
technically correct
yikes
the internet is a mean place
alex is going to want to avoid it for
the next 10 years i think that was
michael malus in disguise yes it
probably was
all right let's see someone asks who is
taking pixar i can't read the name who
was taking pics of alex crying on the
phone his pr or paparazzi
interesting the question that there are
people there taking pictures after it
happened right high-res photos right
that looks like a from
it wasn't a professional
phone or a sign of a sick society that
people are making fun of this guy who
murdered his co-worker on accident
it's probably not a sign of a healthy
happy society yeah not happy that's for
sure ordinarily these types of jokes
would you would make them much later on
after the tragedy has settled tragedy
plus time maybe yeah but this is social
media where people say uh they rushed
right to it yeah and malice is it's not
that he's remorseless i mean he's making
the the the quips that a lot of people
are thinking he just doesn't have the
filter that most people have
but the world needs all types of people
but people have gotten into the habit of
yeah
not waiting well the cool thing with
malice is he punches up he doesn't punch
down yeah and people have different
reaction to trauma some people laugh uh
some people you know are sad but there's
different human reactions too it's dave
chappelle's point as long as you're
really punching up and a lot of the
wokesters have actually been punching
down
those netflix protests proving exactly
what dave chappelle was talking about
and i will say in the instance of alec
baldwin you kind of have to ask yourself
how he would respond if something like
this happened to someone like james
woods what do you think he would be
doing do you think that body would be
cold before he would be being a complete
jerk oh yeah well he's had that
reputation in hollywood for a long time
i only ran into him once and he was an
ass then so i have no sympathy
all right nicholas lipset says saw your
part about buying a guitar right now i
ordered a trumpet in may 2020 should
have taken a couple months i still don't
have it whoa so we went out and bought
the music equipment for doing the shows
here
bought a couple guitars and i went to
the shop and they told me that if you
order a guitar right now it's a 15-month
wait
talk about supply chain issues those are
only going to get worse those are not
going to get better no time soon yeah
they're dumping empty containers on the
side of the road apparently you well you
have problems in china you have problems
with the ships you have problems in the
warehouses and now you're gonna fire a
bunch of workers you're gonna fire
people in warehouses you're gonna fire
them on railroads you're gonna fire them
on trucks because they don't take a drug
they don't want to take and how is that
going to help in canada they've been
talking about you know not overwhelming
the healthcare system from the beginning
it was two weeks to flatten the curve so
as not to overwhelm the healthcare now
they're fi they were talking about
firing thousands of healthcare workers
you even got a honorary coin for it oh
yes that was a that's a good coin we
posted a picture of that on loaders if
anybody wants to see all right brian
perkins says i got my let's go brandon
shirt from luke earlier this week
wore it today and got all kinds of
compliments no hijacking with the real
meaning yeah i mean this is the best way
to make friends i mean there's so much
there's so much speech censored online
we have shirts that i can't wear here
because the the youtube videos will
probably get taken down uh but when i
wear them at the public i get high fives
i get thumbs up i get a lot of people
coming up being like i'm i'm with you
man so if you're in your local community
looking for some friends get a shirt
it's the best way to meet people at
thebestpoliticalshorts.com
ghost actually really is true yeah
seriously people have jokingly said a
tim cass dating site so that the people
who share like similar ideas can date
and i'm like i don't know about all that
but if you see someone wearing a shirt
you're going to be like yo and you're
going to know right away
all right ghost crusader says viva
barnes and tim cast finally together and
only 6k likes hit that like button or at
12k likes right now by the time they
posted it absolutely smash that like
button
tom's pants says ian simulation and
simulacra are two related but different
things read some jean baldrillard is
that a pronunciation
or follow culture camp cast on twitter
to learn about it i watched a great
documentary on that actually and
simulacrum yeah the difference well not
it was it was on the simulacrum yeah
he's got a book called simulation and
simulacrum i think oh interesting
yeah it's like i i think simulacrum a
good
a good example is at the end of the
movie annihilation when what's her face
natalie portman confronts the weird
alien thing mimicking her version like
herself yeah it's like not a real thing
someone just said timder in the comments
[Laughter]
says two days ago twitter suspended me
for saying kyle did nothing wrong
twitter claims it's glorifying violence
they want me to delete the tweet but i
refuse to do so still suspended i
figured robert might be interested in
this info yeah and people give there's
gonna be constant updates about the
trial at free kyleusa.com
and that's where you can get uh there's
other things you can do there won't
mention it on youtube but you can get
the all the updates on the information
he's clearly innocent and it's a it
tells you what era we live in when being
innocent is something that's subject to
censorship oh yeah
western canadian commentary says veteran
here negligent handling of a firearm
resulting in death does that not mean
third degree murder what do viva and
barnes think
it it well it depends i mean look at
what the chauvin trial showed us right
there's going to be very broad and
elastic definitions of various forms of
murder and homicide i mean uh so uh i
mean you look at the insanity of what
they're charging kyle with
if by if those standards were applicable
uh the baldwin would be in jail without
bail tonight uh so that's the way i
would look at it i just i i want to know
the circumstance also because
who was it that mentioned the idea it
might you know whether or not it was
part of the movie whether or not it was
a gag whether or not he was joking
around with it
circumstances details matter his
knowledge of things matter
does he have the innocent canadian
defense that's the key it looks like i
didn't know it
was a loaded gun he can't even say gun
in canada
without going to jail
the gun laws in canada is not is a video
or a discussion for another day it looks
like it wouldn't be a misfire or a
hanging it might have been a hanging
fire but the other uh thing would be a
negligent discharge if it just goes off
in your hand without you pulling the
trigger of a firearm not not if everyone
thought it was a it was a problem
because he very well they just pointed
it and pulled the trigger and thought
nothing was going to happen if this was
the average joe they would be in jail oh
let's just be honest here particularly
if they're politics so what do you do
you go criminally after the production
company for like murder and then alex
baldwin for alec baldwin for
manslaughter i don't think anything like
that will happen because his politics
are on his side uh though i don't know
the local jurisdiction but that's what
normally you would investigate
everything and see whether this was
really an accident because it's it does
seem odd that somebody very familiar
with guns of in that setting which alec
baldwin is would somehow have it go off
and kill somebody
that seems very unexpected unexplained
and his he looks criminal in his
culpability at this stage we don't know
all the details but at this stage yes
interesting
sniper oh link says hey tim i watch you
guys all the time and hear you talk
about shortages i work in retail and
often have to tell customers why we
don't have food
yikes man yeah
let's see how do you pronounce that
dewey cox says in sask canada if you
don't have your qr code passport you can
only go to the grocery store and work
only some work recent election was over
what is it was over fraud
and let that let that sink in also you
need a vaccine passport to get into
certain places where the employees of
those places don't need vaccine
passports
mandate
trust the science i i hated the word
mandate from back in the practice of law
i hated that word and now i hate it
exponentially more and more
mandate me check for bees first said
says all you need to know about the
queen's authority in commonwealth
countries is every officer from dog
catcher prime minister swears obedience
to her
yeah i was just reading about this the
where is it that the queen can dissolve
the house of commons but not the senate
can be dissolved at any time by the
queen of canada
uh or by governor canada the queen of
canada who is the queen of uh england
that would be elizabeth canada the queen
has never exercised his power maybe ever
i i but it's on the books
and typically like it's by prerogative
so that when the prime minister does it
it's deemed to be you know by
recommendation of the queen but i would
have this is
a the monarchy of canada is at the core
of canada's constitutional federal
structure
yeah it still is legal who's next in
line for the crown who is after the
queen you probably don't care so much
megan right
this also says the crown may act on its
own with no advice from any other body
uh in the case of a constitutional
crisis the crown is different than the
queen though um
what's the difference the crown is is
this is the state it's the state it's in
canada but the crown doesn't mean
doesn't mean royalty doesn't mean it
just means the government i mean i have
to look into it i have never even had
the remotest the slightest interest in
what the queen could do because it has
never been a practical question in any
aspect of you know where it comes up
someone want to look up who's the next
island
in island jurisdictions you appeal to
the queen if you get screwed so like my
fraud cases like if it's in guernsey or
someplace like that isle of man you
actually can go up to the queen
technically it doesn't work anywhere but
theoretically figure out i think of them
as like sitting in the road blocking
traffic and being like i'm not doing
anything like people like hey
get out of the way and they're like i'm
not doing anything i'm just sitting here
and you're like well you're you're own
all the land you're doing something
passively by isn't charles the guy who's
like looks like it looks like he's been
he's an exhumed corpse yeah a little bit
like he was in the car and he was like
yeah super old this guy's not doing too
well what if he's just like out of it
and then you know like queen elizabeth
passes because he was just in the
hospital and then as soon as he gets in
he goes he goes nuts and he like
makes crazy declarations and dissolves
australia well for a while they had that
worry because the nazis were recruiting
uh who was it one of the dukes that was
going to could be king back in in the
late 30s they had to hide them out in
the bahamas because he went awol right
he made him renounce i know when we are
venturing out of my area of expertise
same thing
i don't know
it would make life interesting i guess
charles just shows up and he's like
canada's gone australia's gone the
pitcairn islands i'm keeping those he
made some interesting comments about
population control and they do have a
lot of extensive ties to some people
that do really bad things to children
i'm not going to get going here going on
the show here so
all right
neo ritter says you got to cut canada
some slack they've only been a sovereign
country for just shy of 40 years they
still have some time to go before they
figure out that freedom thing hmm
is that true no it's 1867 was when uh
upper and lower canada i'm gonna i hope
i'm not embarrassing myself i took the
course twice 1867 was the unification or
the constitution when did it unify upper
and lower it's existed for uh over 140
years now yeah the confederation 1867.
yeah but there was the unification of
upper and lower canada but then the
constitution of 1867 which was
amended our attitude with not with the
constitution of 1982 which was the one
that was supposed to guarantee
the charter rights
which is what we were discussing charter
privileges tin man says i need little
dancing mushroom toys that scream alex
jones quotes
so i don't know if we in the vlog
there's this really funny comic where
ian goes mushroom hunting and he finds a
mushroom but it's alex jones so the
mushroom is just alex jones talking and
then screaming that'd be good that'd be
good i love it
all right chris h says what do you think
of a unity ticket with desantis gabbard
i think trump's going to win yeah if
trump wanted he's in it's that simple
unless things go something unless
something radically changes between now
and then
oh okay uh homer simp says tim not to be
pedantic but i believe it was called
pasta gate the quebec language police
never recovered from that embarrassment
that was an amazing story when i first
heard it when i was visiting montreal
it's an interesting thing about tim
hortons is like the icon of canada
doesn't have an apostrophe with the s
because under the language laws if you
had an apostrophe in quebec it was an
english
language thing so tim hortons didn't
want to have two brandings for the
product so they just removed the
apostrophe wow there was another one i'm
sure i remember of it called joe's
garage and it was joe's apostrophe
garage he got in trouble with the with
the police the language police and he
covered up the apostasy with the
canadian flag which only made matters
worse but i have not been able to find i
haven't been able to find that story
i'm sure i learned of it in law school
there's a funny old viral video about
the language police where it's like two
guys are doing a drug deal in an alley
and the cops pull up and they try to run
the cops grab them and they're like ah
we got you and they're like no and the
cops push him up against the wall that's
frisking him and then he's like what's
this and he pulls out a bag of weed and
he goes oh sorry he puts it back and
then he pulls he's like wait a minute
and the other cop pulls out an english
language dictionary and he goes
what's this he's like it's not mine i
swear
as an illustration of how preposterous
it is kosher foods and
you like specific market foods would get
in trouble for not having french on it
as if anybody wants to eat the kosher
food stuff in the first place it was
like
you need to have french on this and
that's how
stringent the rules are so
like
they had it had a reason at the time but
if if a law doesn't work after 40 years
maybe it's not going to work in the next
40 years i wonder though like so uh a
company that makes like freezer
cheeseburgers do they create special
packaging that's in french they have to
and or what they do is they go with the
cheaper alternative which is just like
stick over uh labels oh yeah and then
they but that are no words at all
but even though because you have to have
ingredients you have to have nutritional
content there's a bunch of stuff and you
have to literally have either french and
english labeling or just french only and
then what people do is the cheap
alternative print up stickers and have
employees
you know put them over but that adds
cost to doing business in your bank and
it's it's a pain in the neck why why is
english doing better than french though
it's not that it's not doing better it's
not that it's doing better it's that the
idea is that french is on the decline
apparently if you trust the studies
it is
i don't i don't believe it is i think
french people are still speaking french
in quebec uh english people are speaking
english
but everybody's speaking french and
english who wants to speak french and
english but the idea is to protect
french spoken in the home
none of this has anything to do with it
and to allow you know to oblige a
company of 25 employees or more to
operate in french to have contracts
drafted in french and in english even if
somebody wants them drafted in english
it's going to [ __ ] the the economy
and not actually do anything to protect
the french language in my humble opinion
all right let's see trout in alberta
says tim there are canadians that will
riot rural alberta not the cities have
had enough just look to the whistle stop
cafe in mirror alberta what was that
about uh whistle stop i'm not sure about
oh i do know about will stop a couple of
people were held in contempt for
continuing to operate there was the
addams barbecue in ontario some people
have stood up and some people have
gotten massive fines and have taken it
to court
but by and large um
it's a lot i don't promote compliance no
i don't promote non-compliance because
it doesn't get you where you want to go
it's just going to get the government to
come in with more police force
but if people don't want to vote these
people out
the people will get what they want
they'll get what they voted for yeah and
that's what's happening well so it's
interesting because here you know our
police swear enough the constitution and
then when you see these cops going out
and enforcing unconstitutional edict and
mandate i have to wonder you know what
their word actually means
so i'm curious about your relationship
like the canadian people's relationship
with cops
i i would in my in my experience it's
deteriorated would you see cops pepper
spraying dudes at a tim hortons because
they're not wearing a face mask
it has nothing to do with safety it has
to do only with compelled compliance but
i i have never uh
not distrusted but not like seeing the
police around because i don't know what
they're there for are they there to
actually fight actual crime or are they
there because uh an eight-year-old girl
is not isolating in her house because
she crossed somebody with coven i mean i
don't know what they're there to do but
if it's to enforce that stuff they're
not there to enforce the law and it's
it's causing some goodwill uh
issues abolish the police they never
abolish the police but just have the
police should do a job which is justice
and not uh as the good cops start
quitting
you know give it a year or two and
you'll be like man we really should have
abolished them a long time ago because
if the good cops are already going to
quit and the bad cops are going to stay
then it's a win-win for everybody well
especially which about canadian mountain
i mean they're considered the nicest
cops in the world
well quebec i
is that true it is not true they ride
horses which is still kind of kind of
funny but um the quebec police have had
a reputation for being trigger happy in
the past but um no the but the issue is
like they're enforcing things in a way
and quebec has issued tens of millions
of dollars in covent fines it's it's
it's atrocious
all right let's see we got here
kirk hood says ian's passion is great
for the show i like listening to how his
mind works oh
then if you are a member coming to the
event tomorrow you'll you'll get a good
chance to meet him and ian will sing you
songs oh
and whisper sweet nothings into your
ears
writing checks we can't sign
raj rongarian says simulation equals
virtual reality simulacrum equals
augmented reality
interesting
killer donut says do you think biden
will use the national guard to supply
federal uh lno needs the federal prisons
is only about 60 vaccinated 25 at some
institut some of the institutions
p.s uh i don't know that means i'm not
going to read it but uh the other
question yeah i think yes the national
guard will come in they're gonna they're
gonna send a national guard for truck
driving they called the national guard
for driving school buses and where was
it massachusetts that's one of the next
big vaccine mandate cases because they
were given a longer time period to
comply and i've received requests from
everybody i mean i've received requests
from people who work at the white house
to contest the vaccine mandate so it's
much broader what you're talking about
earlier in terms of who's opposing the
social credit system is much broader
than anybody knows people at the federal
reserve want to sue the federal reserve
over it no but the national guard suits
are coming across the country
interesting all right here's one uh for
ian dt qc says the crown is the body
politics which is fused to the body of
the queen this was used to justify how
the queen uh how queen elizabeth could
rule even if she wasn't a man because
her body politics is male oh okay that's
some intense legally legal speak there i
don't know what to like really so dudes
like she's a queen she can't rule ah but
the body politic is male okay she's a
dude that works yeah i know d2qc uh
dtqc's
avatar but i do not know the
truthfulness or the accuracy of that
statement well then i do not doubt it
because he's he's a he's a long time
watcher but uh i don't know that offhand
andrew mckenna wicks says i need a new
shirt that says what am i doing here all
right luke
quote joe biden i need something more
spicy that's like two
i need i need more
all right let's see
says brandon lee was struck in the stock
by a blank that got lodged in the barrel
then expelled by the next shot also how
much uh how much of spec rise do you
think was from people copying pelosi
feed the chickens
uh brandon lee my understanding is that
there was a squib it was a squibby
shadow i was called so it had no
gunpowder but it was supposed to not
have primer but it did have primer
yeah there's a lot of different theories
out there there's a lot of different
conspiracies about that story so there's
different versions of exactly what
happened so i forgot to remove the
primer or something something like that
ladies ladies and gentlemen um they said
wubble up dubbed said feed the chickens
chicken city is nearing absolute
completion
and it is you can see it on my instagram
it's a beautiful chicken fortress it's
got a sewer system so where the chickens
sleep chickens just
you know they just dump where they sleep
and so there's a plastic pan which
funnels down into a duct system that
that rolls it all out so we it's a legit
chicken city it's got a sewer system i
think that makes it a city and here's
the plan that we're going to build once
it's completely done we're going to move
the chickens in there the adults first
we're going to set up cameras for 24 7
chicken livestream
we're going to have different cameras
and adjustable cameras ptz so they can
move around and film other things you're
going to watch the chicken soup chicken
stuff
and then
the ultimate goal
we want to build a machine
that whenever there's a 50 50 super
chats come in
it will rotate dropping treats for the
chickens and there'll be like a maximum
release you know maybe like only 10
times per day but then people who are
watching can you know five bucks and
you'll see the meter fill up and then
once it hits 50 it'll go and the machine
will start spinning and the chickens
will run for it and they'll all be
running around and fighting and the
thing is people need to understand this
chickens play rugby
you guys know this that's what it's
called uh if you throw in like a bug one
chicken will pick it up and then run and
they'll all chase
each other
and they'll try and take the food from
each other's mouths but they're like
they run around and they're dodging and
jumping it's like really fun to watch
the 24 7 is good i've never seen a
chicken actually lay an egg no meaning i
would be interested to see that that's
right and we can we'll put cameras in
the roosting boxes they just sit there
so it's there's a bunch of them we'll
figure out they're like roosting in the
same place but we'll put a camera and
then
you don't really see anything sometimes
the chickens will be running and the egg
falls out i've seen an ostrich give or
give birth lay an egg and that's they're
quite shocking there's some crazy
developments according to the daily mail
surrounding the alec baldwin case i
don't know if you want me to read it but
the daily mail pull it up the daily mail
story um i don't know but they're
reporting right now that when uh
he was told that he needed to shoot the
scene again baldwin joking no no no no
no no that's that's actually it's on the
daily mail because i heard that's not
true that's that's what some people are
reporting right now i read i read that
this morning that he jokingly was like
i'll shoot you
but that was not true those are some of
the reports i see going around twitter
right now and again yeah the police
department are still uh investigating it
we don't know what happened which um
there is an update though apparently he
was told the gun was safe so that's the
latest update
he there that
big big updates but yeah apparently
someone went to him and told him the gun
was safe that's what they're reporting
you know his crisis communications team
is in overdrive yeah
non-union assistant director handed him
prop gun after workers walked offset
over poor conditions
yikes man
we got a big event tomorrow there's
gonna be a lot of people there
some people who just happen to be in the
area for some reason that's right might
actually be there as well mm-hmm so make
sure you go to tmcs.com become a member
we were trying to do events all year i i
many of you probably know this and it's
just not easy to do that's why one of
the reasons i'd love for this county to
become a part of west virginia but we uh
we got free damastan
which uh we're gonna build a big stage
and we're gonna have events there
we're gonna try and figure it out it's
it's complicated stuff insurance cost
and all that stuff but you know we we
ultimately want to have the events be
free for members when they spring up
limited availability obviously but
that's what we're doing here i don't
know if we'll be able to do an event for
november and december because the
holidays and it's going to be cold
we'll figure it out maybe but then um
you know january february march we'll
try and do events once a month in the
area maybe you know we'll see what
happens with the lockdowns and the
enforcement stuff but uh yeah become a
member at timecast.com smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends follow us at
tim cast irl on all platforms you can
follow me personally at tim cast do you
guys want to shout anything out yeah if
you want to follow us at
vivabarnslaw.locals.com that's where our
community exists and that's where you
can get exclusive content all year round
it is a treasure trove of information on
locals uh robert and i are both on
twitter barnes underscore law on twitter
viva fry on twitter oh the viva fry not
viva fry that's a unrelated russian
account oh yeah
and before i forget why do you have two
machetes on the table well for when when
we first had the new studio there was a
there was a sword here my sword someone
took it away from me no sorry i got my
own shirt i got my own shorts it was
here on the table okay it was a free
sword so i decided to you know i was
like
so anyway i'm very excited about
tomorrow's event and if you want to see
me leading the charge of the let's go
brandon chance you can because i'm going
to be posting about it on my twitter and
instagram stories all under luke we are
change luke we are change on instagram
and twitter and my youtube channel is we
are change and it's great to see some of
you guys there thanks for watching it
was so good to have you guys here uh the
energy is good and the information is
good i like luke you said earlier there
i wanted more so hopefully we can do
this again i would love to have you guys
back sometime there was a bar you
mentioned earlier oh yeah someone had
messaged me and tonight people are going
to be out people that are in town for
the uh event and the name of the bar i'm
going to the barn the barn that's easy
barnes it's in harper's ferry it's
called the barn the bar the barn with an
end
people may be there hanging out if you
go check around there are people that
are going to be attending the event
tomorrow going to be hanging out there
when kayla for mel sent me the message
so thanks kayla for letting me know
and uh then we'll see you guys tomorrow
yeah i am stoked i looked up this quote
that someone uh super chatted us that
tim didn't want to read because that's
how people get you it is latin and i
could almost figure it out but i had to
look it up it is montani semper liberi
which is from the latin and it means
mountaineers are always free it is the
state motto of west virginia now we know
i feel
but that's that's that makes more sense
yeah exactly yeah i like it anyway i am
super excited about tomorrow um you guys
may follow along on my twitter at sour
patch lids
all right it's gonna have to be an early
bedtime because we're gonna get there
early we got to set up we we we have no
idea what we're doing we're we get some
amps a pa some microphones and just
figure it out and uh that's whatever you
know we'll be there and uh we'll you
know we'll be working all day tomorrow
so thanks for watching the show and for
everybody who's coming out we'll see you
there and for everyone who missed it
there'll be more to come and we'll make
sure we get you so thanks for hanging
out we'll see y'all next time bye guys
you